way so this actually might work okay
hey maybe we don't have to really yeah I
was looking forward to confusing people
I know what it's working we're in this
is a rare occurrence we're in like Flynn
thought it was broke but turns out it
was only slightly broke it's gonna be a
relaxing livestream it's gonna be so
relaxing
low-key you're gonna be like why am I
here this is boring there's gonna be a
boring lives when I my plan is to set
the bar so low no matter what we do it's
gonna be good I love it I love how we
didn't even ask you guys can we hear can
you hear us and so many of you guys are
already going we can hear you you are
debuffed
you guys know how it goes so a lot of
the country doesn't realize this yet
a lot of the world the corona virus is
still long going so we ought to be
quarantine as much as possible just so
you know it does seem like inconvenient
as it might be you you have to be we
have to be quarantined convenience is
the American Dream and in within this
time hey Aaron first time to lie okay
first off let's split backtrack John
let's say hi to some folks in the chat
Erik horseman is here of course Arian
Hodge rah Arian Hara first time here
shall be Irish Nixon boo yay this is
your first time here immediately hit the
like button before you even experience
the live stream that's what we like to
say the other thing I would say is yeah
these are you know we never know how
these go sometimes we stay on topic
other times you really go off on a
tangent sometimes John does impressions
and I do the splits you never know
what's gonna happen yeah cautery is a
James it's goki 101 Maria Hammond how
you doing Ashley Hoover Mimi chill level
TV is in the chat what's going on guys
it's all ogre now Rose your first stream
welcome here how's it going Brian Beatty
dawn Rex from Texas
whoo taint generator so many cool [ __ ]
names in this chatt generation jazz love
we love you too and Laura McDonald how's
it going next car we could do the whole
stream just just saying hi to people in
the chat that's what we are that's what
we ought to do one one day we'll just
only read name that'll be the theme of
that one stream and then whoever gets
reading off your name favorite name I
did see the Halloween kills a teaser
trailer I didn't they mean yeah that's
cool oh [ __ ] the fire department they
[ __ ] us over and it's also kind of
like a Nelson Muntz like goddamn fire
department Michael Myers still alive
[ __ ] fire department say the second
movie or the third movie I guess we call
it in you know it'll be the police
department that this saves and yes and
then the last one it'll be like an
ambulance that says the pro 24 welcome
DLC all right guys so today's stream
we're gonna be talking about things
we've been catching up on we might talk
about Hamilton
huh hope you're not gonna miss our shot
to talk about it that's my that's my
lin-manuel Miranda everyone else sounds
so cool in the memo Miranda he's cool he
[ __ ] rap great freestyler my Mickey
Mouse and lin-manuel is the same and
neither one are good which one's better
I want to watch the old guard tonight
and watch the old guard tonight is that
what it's called old Guardian
oh the old guard with Charlize Theron
yeah I want to watch that tonight and I
started up Umbrella Academy ooh
Gerard Way I really feel like this this
dream is gonna be the most podcast sea
of them all My Chemical TV show and I
finished all this surprise Danny Dibble
welcome I've
just all of the Sopranos Haley actually
even though I knew how it ended it cuts
to black just like how all our lives but
I still there was a couple of really big
I thought there was this major plot to
us that I never heard about that occurs
like in the episode book to me the real
last episode is the episode of the
penultimate one but yeah John what have
you caught up on so far kind of been a
bunch of things but lately for some
reason I have been catching a lot of
like a tease period Creature Features so
like I recently rewatched the original
tech Clash of the Titans
nice beasts master nice and what was the
other one there was another one that had
like a lot of big monsters in it the
name will come back to me for but but
yeah like a lot of like Ray Harryhausen
or Sinbad that's what we saw one of the
Sinbad movies with the old og Ray
Harryhausen like you know claymation
effects and whatnot and some of those
creatures and stuff still hold up really
well so earlier this week we did a
reaction I saw someone in the chat
mentioned it at man Houston about the
boys being the best TV show ever and
then the reaction we did I mentioned you
know you haven't seen the boys John gave
you some [ __ ] about it yeah thing is I
thought I had answered it the boys know
you it's been my goal away [ __ ] but in
doing my taxes I was like I'll spend
money on an always an account next week
always an excuse cause I found out oddly
enough that my sisters Amazon Prime
family plan only means that you get
shipping benefits it you do all of you
don't get that Amazon Prime video access
so I got a drop that $13 Wow all those
days this week where I had time to watch
TV
screw me tomorrow one episode of days
all I gotta say I'll start tomorrow
anywho we'll see John we'll see mm-hmm
all you got to do was put pressure on
John and he'll eventually do it there's
much like real-life work to get done I
don't know how you like your viewing I
get I I wrote the whole thing over the
weekend and shot and edited that whole
[ __ ] hell did I do this right see
there's always you just gotta make time
time management quit getting distracted
with all that pornography you're
watching yeah okay every time I come in
the office he's coming in the office
welcome to the live I watched the
probation I watched the porn night
anywho yeah I'm seeing a lot of great
comments near so far I don't want to
fall too behind on some of these I see a
lot of you guys have been super chatting
already and I appreciate that really do
really do and also we have stream labs
as well would take less of a cut so you
know we like that one too but hey let's
catch up on some of these super chats as
we go through the regular chats as well
hey gene Jeter welcome to the chat I'm a
gauze what does that mean oh don't worry
which because I'm white I do that and I
do that boom here we go all right so we
got some super chats to go through those
who you guys have been saying the Agora
bowl the agoraphobic fanboy who can also
be dating someone like Carter Lovejoy I
make a dildo out of a agoraphobic fanboy
make it my homeboy little dildo toy
everyone's gonna get a failed freestyle
shoutout today agoraphobic certainly not
homophobic
but definitely hetero phobic make of
that what you will
re-watch the Terminator films dark fate
doesn't deserve all the hate in
retrospect at least not a majority of it
stay safe and healthy everyone you know
what dude I like all the Terminator
films except for salvation and you got
to understand Terminator 2 Judgment Day
is one of my favorite fell
of all time it's usually battered matrix
that list is number one favorite movie
and I even have a lot of fun were rising
the machines dr. gland and soldier
General William kid that's a deleted
scene I know but it's still rise DG cuts
deep cuts and then I think Terminator
genocide is also fun and I even have fun
with Terminator dark fate despite the
fact that we did a spoiler review where
we just talk [ __ ] on them they maybe
didn't just bill it as like no guys this
is the real Terminator 3 yet maybe it
would have been a little less impact and
so yeah I mean I'll give it up to your
agoraphobic fanboy who has a best friend
named Roy and who he takes his ass and
destroys Eddie and also everyone's going
to get if you're a guy a gay shadow
people in desperate need of trying to
get through a freestyle shout out on a
live stream I resort to gage Oaks that's
what I do today so Eric horsemen I
better hear from you and hear buddy it's
okay don't don't don't worry everybody's
pointing out your bars right now these
are not good bars they're [ __ ] fire
bars just you know warm up for a while
okay so then I think thank you
agoraphobic fanboy who's next on the
list here and yes someone Maria and the
chat is asking about that I watched the
canoe scene in The Sopranos you bet your
ass I did I have some theories of how is
that The Sopranos truly ended yes it was
a deep cut reference right yes don't
watch Invisible Man if you're
trypophobia I love that comment
oh is that when you can't handle like a
lot of small dots in one place okay so
the next one on the on the super chats
Peter Pacheco loves to eat a good nacho
while it's munching on some talk I don't
need the beat the beats only gonna [ __ ]
me up because I'm gonna try to go on
your beat but I'll give you a beat if
you want to go for one night I can write
a good rap I'm working on freestyling in
the car
so we got Peter Pacheco like what did I
say he likes to eat a good taco and much
on some nachos and Pacheco rode on the
rodeo and he likes to go and grab some
Froyo with okay we're done Peter Pacheco
you've got all you got enough rhymes the
Shire gunfire he's girl pyar give me 20
more wraps my lights down starting good
he said uh your protector said she
watched Godfather soccer wait a minute
re-watch Oh or she watched maybe she
watched Godfather saga first time we are
in the middle of season one for Doom
Patrol
I get bail I'm like your wife or
daughter or grandma Artemis Fowl not
good mid Samar me and Jon watch the boys
you hear that [ __ ] hi everyone
live stream better be saying
Jon watch the boys - tag Jon watch the
boys alright I mean if that's the
cultural movement I get hashtagged with
okay hey man so I don't know who you
showed I don't know who you're saying
she - you're referencing someone in this
watching The Godfather saga for the
first time I showed my girlfriend
Godfather one and two and I said let me
just tell you what happens let her take
a shot I just couldn't couldn't do that
foot to her man couldn't do it to her
have you seen Godfather 3 yet no oh you
are missing out
hashtag Jon watch guys I'm talking about
on watch the bullet that's called
engagement here in middle of season one
for Doom Patrol so I had a toss-up
between start Doom Patrol or start
Umbrella Academy because there's a
couple of shows that I've been asked to
react to and there's a couple I kind of
just want to hurry up and catch up on
because I hate missing out on trailers
so Doom Patrol was one I so it was
either Umbrella Academy or Doom Patrol
and I went with them I kind of just did
a coin toss and I went with the Umbrella
Academy I'm only on season 7 of season
season seven two days [ __ ] impressive
ISM I'm pulling an episode 1 of season I
quit Michelle I'm on episode 7 of season
1 and it's a brilliant show is it it's a
brilliant show it's so weird it's first
it starts off like an Agatha Christie
superhero show and then it just gets
like really bizarre and characters that
I don't like become likeable who it's a
great [ __ ] show if you guys haven't
seen Umbrella Academy I'm not even done
with the first season yet but do it
there is another hashtag new role check
with a Greg watch Shawshank
oh that's Greg watch Shawshank watch
Shawshank and Greg watch Forrest Gump
I appreciate that guys don't worry if
people are starting to do movie
reactions on YouTube and some are doing
like n game and hereditary I'll do
Shawshank it force come do the Godfather
3 trilogy right there you see other
people are already covering the big
energetic movies to do movie reactions
for we're gonna do the hard-hitting
dramas for you god yes let's get those
Chernobyl reactions going but thanks
Peter Pacheco alright who's next
Lynnae jones Lynnae jones who likes the
munch on some ice cream cones and never
does she ever get stoned because she
lives with her grandparents in the home
that's the best one I'm leaving it there
no more thanks that was Joan's flippin
fire it's a John Boyer
Johnny Lynnae says hey guys I have
recently lost both oh goodness I'm not
gonna read this in a funny voice I'm
sorry I should have read that before
doing her shadowed I'm so sorry I
recently lost both my grandparents last
week within 36 hours of what the show
I've been watching is Doom Patrol on HBO
that is an ape I mean I'm not gonna give
your Instagram handle on here but
private message me I'm sorry to hear
that my dear yeah seriously I remember
she would always talk about her
grandparents cooking and she always made
it sound like the most
delicious [ __ ] [ __ ] in the world yeah
like she made me want to go to Texas
just to try out her grandparents cooking
and now close you are with them 36 hours
apart Jesus Christ but Doom Patrol
hopefully that's helping you get through
the grieving process my here be safe be
safe I don't know what the cause is but
be safe okay but message me privately
because yeah it's been a while since I
heard from and I'm sorry to hear about
hopefully we can get your mind off
things for a little bit during this
stream yeah okay with that in mind we
should redo a shout-out right we should
do a redo a shout out okay Lynnae jones
loves to watch Game of Thrones and now
she'll be getting stoned and she'll call
me up on the phone and I'm gonna give
over a good bone Nick put the first lady
bone she'll get a lady boner is a piece
of a penis that's there's not a
one-to-one there I'm sorry this
shout-out is really much better than the
trusty five for life is saying I should
stop no never
I need you to know it's only gonna get
worse from here only so many rhymes down
but thank you lenay rizzo gaming ryan
Beatty okay do we do we rhyme we're with
rizzo gaming or do we rhyme with Ryan
baby mmm
lately I've been thinking about Ryan
Beatty and I gotta say he brings out the
shady with inside of me cuz Ryan at
night you have me crying and I can't be
lying this is my this is my lin-manuel
Miranda
his actual vocal temper also just sorry
hashtag what happened to Marie sorry
there was like a whole interlude in this
life where you were like remember my old
neighbors here yeah man I found Marie
she's like she was like many states away
now well thanks for at least bringing
her up but Rizzo game oh yeah sorry
hey guys been feeling really damn low
the past four you died so this is just
what I need to feel a bit better so
thanks Cheers
my lady Ryan Beatty invites us all don't
know B in fact what Ryan baby's voice
sounds like go watch our watch lungs or
well just go watch series two episodes
five and six and Jake the blonde guy
sounds like Ryan Beatty
thank you Greg and M is in the house
here and whole game it's gonna be an
up-and-down experience alright we'll do
one one or two more Super chats and then
let's see what guys keep listing in the
live streams what [ __ ] you've been
catching up on because I always like it
if I often forget what I've watched so
if you guys sometimes people will say
something and I'll be like oh yeah I did
see that and I like that feeling and
John does too I speak for John here love
that alright Michael Mac Michael Mac
thank you Michael Mac mm-hmm I come to
attack with the Michael Mac he's got a
nice rack he like he wants to see the
release of the Zack attack of the
Schneider cut hell yeah those bars
Michael Mac be looking all jacked and he
you put him up on a stack and you want
to go through your [ __ ] [ __ ]
Michael hi guys it is awesome by the way
I've been watching mr. robot during
lockdown and holy ships Wow it's amazing
only got five episodes rami malek and
Christian Slater are both okay very nice
man nothing but top praise about that
show yeah I haven't seen mr. robot I
thought I've seen Bohemian Rhapsody
different
he's just hacking the music
very with great tunes yeah I've okay
John what did you think of it we both
watch Hamilton never did a review no but
John what did you think of Hamilton
I enjoyed Hamilton quite a bit it's it's
I mean you know it's it's a thick piece
but I think the music is terrific I
think there's a lot of incredible
performance work on display I you know
it's one of those things where once I
finished it I was like okay it'd be
curious to see like what lines up with
history and what doesn't but as you know
a tour de force of a music hold that is
just music from front to back and as
something that attempts to take the
founding fathers and portray them like
you know regular difficult you know
nuanced people rather than these you
know deities that we hold them up as
throughout history you know I thought it
was really effective deities history you
have a little rhyme there I'm just
saying oh I'm a poet
it wasn't aware yes so okay we'll give a
quick Hamilton that was John's little
mini Hamilton review I'll talk about
Hamilton really fast now we just did a
reaction for patron to the kid cudi
video with Eminem and I used it as a way
to talk about Hamilton for some reason
afternoon man slim shadey review is
about Hamlet so okay I'm gonna be honest
with you guys you guys might know that
back in the day I used to smoke so much
weed and now I don't smoke anywhere near
intake and anytime I talk about if I
ever take weed people usually click off
the stream notice some like real anti
weed view here fine so I don't ingest
weed anywhere near as much as I used to
there although I could go many many days
without it
on this particular day I happen to have
ingested some weak I put on Hamilton
yeah well my girlfriend I really wanted
to watch it I was looking forward to it
and and and there's a couple of things
that went wrong one is hey I forgot all
about who Alexander Hamilton is and I
feel like that's a big part of it right
is like remember the Forgotten founding
father
I I was like oh yeah as we were doing it
oh yeah and this couple of things one my
brain was not ready to keep over that
much a little bit of a challenging
experience video so we definitely needed
subtitles and I would occasionally have
to possibly like what did they just rap
about okay I got it
secondly it was about ten minutes in
where I was not aware because I was
whenever you do something with a period
piece of especially that time in
American history I become aware of and I
feel like it's kind of natural to be
aware of like races right and everyone
knows I'm the like last person all right
when a people all the time move get crap
about it when you go that far back in
time yeah you start to wonder about if
there's diverse casting I start to
wonder what's in line with the time so
when I was watching it it took me like
15 minutes to realize race does not
factor into this play and so Thomas
Jefferson not black we're cutting oh
he's way before now and I realize it's
the same before Georgia look at all
these different diverse characters I was
like I had to pause ago wait race does
not factor into this cuz that was kind
of confused for a second I'm so used to
watching a piece of American history and
it's such a bad so much about that that
an Tanya if if I didn't ingest a little
bit of a gummy I would have been fine as
it stands though upon reflection and
especially by the time that this stuff
was wearing off it's a really [ __ ]
impressive play you know what I don't
get about what some of the reviews are
saying with this that I find so so silly
with Hamilton specifically is how people
are like it's not captured like there's
any stupid [ __ ] like it's like after
like a film it doesn't translate well
for fit like they're saying it doesn't
like because you have to be far away
it's it it's not captured like a movie
even though there are some close-up
shots I'm like that's the point the poor
to capture a filmed play yeah it's it's
it's the best film play ever its I have
seen some film plays before and this is
easily the most engaging shot one I've
ever seen it's really well shot and also
he liked defeat Diggs was my favorite
part of it
my other favorite part equally favorite
part was the mine hunter guy Oh Jonathan
gruff and I didn't remembered I didn't
realize jonathan groff that's his
background
I always knew him as the mine hundred
guy that everyone's like oh he's frozen
yeah I thought he was awesome so funny
that spit saliva thing was distracting
he says it's intentional I don't know
either way he was amazing there's a
little review for Hamilton and daveed
Diggs is a national treasure go go
listen to a clipping album listen to
Bloch blind spotting watch my watch by
that I need to watch blinding this
that's what is because I hate all race
the reason I couldn't see past the
diversity in the first 10 minutes was
because you Joe that's right my bonus
I'm just my affinity for white stuff
alright we'll do we'll do one more
really quick yes from okay some other
someone who's saying I have this same
exact moment in the chat so thank you I
was like wait is this like some
subconscious little racist part of my
brain I just not seen I could totally
imagine a couple people being like wait
wait what I could see it throwing some
people yeah especially in America where
we don't study history very well the
doorbell rang and opened the door it was
Britney laying and then she's saying hey
guys
long time no talk how's it goin it's
been a hot minute the hottest minute
it's a hundred degree minute today it's
hot as [ __ ] and we don't have our fan in
here which was my fault I usually bring
it in here before it you know what it's
okay little manatee yeah
we are not high don't worry and we're
not drunk either some people are asking
or not not yet
yet not with not with all this bottle of
vodka in this story yeah
this is just pure alcohol 100% all of it
it's rubbing alcohol rubbing alkaline it
evaporates pretty fast so you got it
down the hall Thank You Brittany Lang
love your new profile pic by the way
it's nice to see you out face um okay oh
I see some of you guys contribute your
stream labs thank you gonna be hopping
over there in just a second but I want
to go through the chat to see what some
of y'all are saying in here really quick
Robert Becerra pointed out catch me if
you can which is a movie that I have
seen a couple times actually on TV and
Quarantine or at least you know caught
again catch me if you can made me fall
in love with DiCaprio so good it's funny
catch me on Hanratty cow Hanratty yeah
that movie and the Aviator have been on
a ton lately so I've seen both of those
in recent but uh catch me if you can't
man that that and I would say the
terminal or two underrated Stevi spiel
joints yes yes yes hang see guys go for
drones 88 6-3 best channel in the world
oh yeah hater
there's too much going on in Hamilton to
see it hi I I tie welcome here there's a
you a soft event tomorrow - Maria
Hammond hated hated aviator way of the
future
I can I can understand why some people
might not love it but I think there's a
lot of quality work on display I feel
like a lot of people in the chat
genuinely really love Hamilton hell yeah
genuinely really hate the 80s
okay you know what else I caught up on
what the last of us to watch that review
and you know what else like God John
what did I catch up on there's something
else I watched I definitely watched
something other than umbrella watch many
other things since then was it a
documentary the Jim Jefferies special I
really liked and the George Lopez
special and the Thomson I watch a lot of
stand-up
comedy and the Tom Segura Netflix
special I thought was really really
[ __ ] funny that was my favorite of
the three the Tom Segura Netflix special
[ __ ] hysterical if you guys haven't
seen listen if you're looking for a good
stand-up comedy listen to Tom Seguros
latest special dude [ __ ] cracked me up
dude is I feel like are our friends Tony
and Courtney are especially big Tom
Segura fan are they yeah I think so
I actually just watched the new Hannibal
Buress stand-up which was pretty
enjoyable I didn't laugh when I was
watching it really at all at any part
not even the auto-tune not really with
the the tracheotomy
I learned it I like I just like
listening to Hannibal Burres his
thoughts but I wasn't I didn't find it
that funny all right
there's been other ones I haven't
listened to I love Hannibal Burres I
listened to the whole Joe Rogan podcast
with him and I I just love listening the
way the guy thinks and and he made me
laugh a lot more that podcast yeah yeah
I like the new one more than comedy
kamisato
although it might not be among his best
but I thought the use of technological
embellishments was a lot more smooth
than I was expecting when it first end
yes so I thought that was a cool thing
for him to do um I also kept Mike after
mail comes out on July 18 by the way
just saying hey Alex how are you Katy
Orlando so the goddamn there was
something there was something else I
watched I really hit me and I can't
remember what it is right now but it was
good all of John Campea Zepa so maybe I
don't know doesn't matter and ghosts in
the dark recently
oh oh yeah no I got I got one episode
left of Hannibal I've been saying that
for the longest time I just can't find
the motivation to get around for some
reason eat less you watched a show
called stateless no that was just the
trailer for it never mind you finished
code yeah you know what the problem is
it's like during the time of quarantine
there was a solid like week and a half
or I didn't watch anything because it
was all dedicated to either finishing
The Sopranos or playing The Last of Us -
I didn't catch up on a lot of it on page
I'll finish like Gotham and code geass I
love those two shows those are great
you've been watching more movies and
shows than I have yeah I catch them just
not the boys I suppose not
I when it's like just my sole viewing
time that's not really a thing I usually
wind up watching stuff with like when my
family is eating dinner why don't you
watch anything on your own
cuz usually I'm working then what are
you you're working you come here to work
life is all work no it's not what do you
mean working come here to work what are
you doing I don't see anything that's
really happening you should have left we
watched you should have left oh yeah we
watched that and we watched irresistible
anime bleach oh I've been wanting to
watch that as well my I really want to
watch what's it called samurai Champloo
is that the one who the guy who did
cowboy beep ahh that's the other one I
really want to watch I thought Shampoo I
thought you started with Olivia back at
the old apartment a long time ago I need
to start again as I remember anything
that happened in there and then now
let's see yeah but I mean I I finished
the clone I've been watching the Clone
Wars in chronological order and I
finished the movie and I just haven't
gotten around to it since and I hear the
movies like the weakest part of all the
Clone Wars so I feel like I just need to
hurry up and get to 2 there basically is
after watching the Clone Wars movie just
get on to the next episode right away
because I yeah I mean I thought the
movie was fine I just didn't I didn't
hate it to the degree that everyone
seems to dog it alright let's go into
here alright Jon Jon how do we pull this
up since it's the same way we pull up
the other thing just with a different
spatial mechanic
oh I watch Green Lantern how was that
that was fun watch Ryan Reynolds it was
bad it was bad it wasn't good if I saw
when I first came out I would have hate
it even more but I think after hearing
about how terrible that movie is for so
many years yeah it wasn't as bad as
everyone else
made it out to be that's a nice what
it's pretty surprised it's not good but
it wasn't the worst thing in the world
oh goodness
we have hitman hitman Hudson in the
stream labs dashboard thank you for the
love my sister is a mean person
John John what are you doing you're
shouting out hitman Hudson he didn't
even get a freestyle shoutout oh go hit
man Hudson over here pushing my buttons
driving me out of my mind I got no more
time for your [ __ ] so let's look
back take a tick on the time clock hits
you in the nutsack
ouch rhyme Hudson hit man Hudson click
the button put my nuts in yo mouth my
sister is a mean person so could I marry
her off to one of you so I don't have to
deal with her anymore
I'll pay a large dowry wow that's far
glad you reached for the the vocab word
dowry yeah John go marry hitman Hudson
sister boy you're out of the house who's
your sister is she good person beyond
the fact that you guys don't get along
is she mean to you or mean to everyone
cuz they say that you can only do you
need to judge people by how they treat
folks that can't do anything for them
but I feel like you can't judge people
on how they treat their brother or
sister okay that's fair man but if your
sisters hot John will marry her sorry to
all the ladies in the chin it's the way
it goes it's all John cares about looks
yep it's how you look not how you feel
you know John and I know John or for a
long time all about looks with the gal
about it later once looked at the
personality I don't have a personality
of my own and you should buy two okay
all right John you get one more shot
tongue punch far out from the school of
hard knocks comes the tongue punch
fart box punching the clocks to give us
a tip look at just the tip hook it yeah
I was like once I get on a roll it's
like boy I know you're like oh yeah now
I'm gonna roll gutter balls the whole
rest of the time that's the thing that
drives me insane because like I can
write wordplay for days but like to do
it in a freestyle is like this weird
zone that I have to like completely lock
on and it rarely happens so maybe today
I'm in there by myself things I wonder
if I feel like I can freestyle when I'm
singing but when I'm literally trying to
rap or flow or do it spoken it's much
harder there's someone in the chatters
dis in our camera get us a new camera
get us a new camera a new capture card
we can it's mostly because we're running
HD video through a capture card thousand
dollars were streaming that H to spend
more all right Thank You TM I appreciate
it all right
tongue punch fart box finally finish
catch it up on my hero academia started
Hunter hunter four episodes in I will
also watch your reactions as well love
you guys thank you buddy
I know it's Deonte right Deonte dub yeah
thanks for being here dude my hero
academia so my girlfriend she just like
huggin Winterbottom binge all the way
the [ __ ] through attack on Titan in like
two days it's not healthy but she loves
it and she was trying to go back and
forth scene attack on Titan in my hero
academia and I was like you don't want
to do that to you yeah like if you love
attack on time and so much more you
can't properly enjoy my hero like a
different show yeah and one's like way
more serious and mature than the other
and so she finished tagging outside and
now she's like on season three I think
core close to from my hero and she's
been enjoying it more
so yeah and Hunter hunter hunter is a
real up and down show sometimes it's
like the best anime ever and then
sometimes it's like boring you know a
really fluctuate he hit or miss it
sometimes it can be like that
consistently and then sometimes it's
like on a roll for a while for a long
they're like oh maybe we're past all the
other uh nevermind we're back and then
suddenly oh that's great again but yeah
I but the hunter Hunter has too many
great episodes to to not recommend it
that's that's the thing with it yeah
it's like its greatness definitely
outweighs whatever it can be kind of
meandering from time to time all the
anime fans in this show like ever since
I've brought this video up so many times
now and and like every time we talk
about anime I just want to know what
everyone's thoughts are but there's a
long beach griffey sketch where he's
doing like anime fans and how they
behave and it's he just runs through the
fans of a bunch of different shows and
like half of them are the shows we're
watching on patreon so I'm saying I'm
like oh like is how are people gonna
feel because like you know some of those
I don't know like its yeah I just want
to know what everyone's reaction is fill
your man it's a funny a sketch oh we got
Eric horseman in the chat know your name
buddy oh oh we got a freestyle shout you
out
Eric was here Eric horse Oh horseman
sense what is so much harder what about
Johnny Five for life oh we miss joy I'm
so sorry Johnny Five for life we don't
want to skip why do you hate Johnny Five
for life that's why you're here John for
short because you don't like short
circuit you think shows there's a better
working non-stop
once you're not here apparently so you
can't watch the boys wait there's like
life [ __ ] that you have to do when
you're done with like business work or
well yes it's life work you just call it
work maybe that's the Association you
can't associate it with just being work
there's life and okay like your tasks
the things that need we all maintain
well yeah of course we do I'm just
saying you can make time to watch the
boys I suppose just a lot of things go
for employer watching are you watch
movies you watch Django Unchained again
when
on Stardust it says I have the Stardust
app don't I well you find that I'm gonna
rap about one month ago well since this
life it's the last time we did this
subject sometimes I don't know okay I
probably I'll give you the benefit of
johnny-five for life well you say you
want to rap about Johnny Five for life
had you think of a bunch of rhymes in
this entire time I was making fun of you
for now watching the boys go for a John
no I mean if you want to rap about
Johnny Five for life hey be my guest so
he'll be my wife no do it do it go you
don't even realize I'm about to cut
through this with Ockham's knife it's
what everything it's simple there's only
so many words you trouble eyes strife
write strife life knife wife it's always
the same
Emma five I'm paying up for charity that
call that a tithe I rise on the floor
when I'm in pain let's just read his
let's just read his thing hey John just
one old guard on Netflix earlier today
loved it
Charlize Theron is so good I am already
down for a sequel either you know I
started off this I had a feeling people
might bring that up so I'm gonna try to
watch old guard tonight actually I
probably will I want to have these
excuses that John has to not watch I
just don't like TV or content that
people want to watch and I don't
definitely it's okay John no I haven't
seen it yet but I heard it's amazing
I've heard the act I've heard the action
to say the least is pretty great I
wonder if the action in that movie is
better than then extraction didn't they
say they got the people from atomic
blonde like someone from there to work
on the old guard probably I think I
heard something to that effect and I
wouldn't be surprised if Charlize there
and especially for like another action a
joint wanted to bring similar people
over
I mean Charlize Theron is in my opinion
I think she's
very underrated talent because she can
do any John rrah
yeah Furio soldier that's her name right
through yo soul osa not furious aw I
forget you know that's why your that's
why do you do better than me in the
Schmo down take yeah the second round of
inter geekdom really proves that so and
then she can be hilarious and films like
long shot and then she could just be a
great dramatic actress like in movies
like Aeon Flux a monster and and she's
also in no doubt the the jason reitman
movie what the [ __ ] is that called it's
a great one she has sex with Patton
Oswalt yeah that one she's wonderful in
that movie so yeah Charlize there's an
underrated gem and she could do a whole
all the genres and I feel like she
doesn't get enough credit for that yeah
that's true she should just be like oh
hot actress who's like you know town
she's she's kind of like the I feel like
Margot Robbie is kind of like going
through a Charlize Theron phase I feel
like she cooks like she comes on the
scene she's really great-looking actress
and she's talented and now she's gonna
do it all it's like wide variety of
roles as well you know what I mean man I
could see it happening I mean cuz Margot
Robbie also seems game for anything and
exactly Erin also has that vibe about
her and plus she still looks like 20
years old I know she doesn't age that's
her best gift you know just be from
South Africa alright Eric Whitacre soon
we're back to you Thank You Johnny high
for life alright John do we rhyme
Eric was here or do we do Eric horseman
horseman sounds tougher so I'm kind of
tempted to give Eric horseman a shot
because let's face it we're killing it
Eric horseman got a testicular torsion
sounds horrid eat some porridge maybe
you'll feel better and then put on a
sweater Eric horse maybe used to take
done four-story leaves such am I run
such a big donation we should we should
like maybe do one one of his names that
it alright
okay you too Eric I'll think of
something
with with whatever Olivia you know yeah
you in the chat I'm a cleric worship at
the altar of Eric oh good yeah that one
guy with the holy fire sword from Game
of Thrones his name was barek and the
Elephant Man John Merrick oh yeah and
now stare at me watch try and come up
with more Ronny so good thanks alright
Horstmann Horstman I listened to the
song porcelain and I think of Eric
Horstman and he rides a horse as we call
him a horseman and through my veins his
his love is coursing and I feel like I
should give him an endorsement we gotta
have a punctuation there no it was good
Oh anyways you're in trouble in the chat
oh no it's because I said someone as I
said either [ __ ] Charlize Theron or
Margot Robbie's hot and that didn't go
over well with Olivia yes you're
watching her choice of TV he said
expanding my anti-racist knowledge oh
yeah just a few to name when they see us
dear white people 13th blind spotting
horror noise a history of black horror
[ __ ] noir horn or I just imagine Eric
is this is this white guy going I'm not
racist I'm not racist I'm gonna watch
only things he's got the like alligators
like eyeball prior opener things on just
watching so much historical anti-racist
material I mean I'm glad you got blind
somebody man that one's [ __ ]
incredible and I got MIT I got I need to
watch more of what you listed here but
you're doing the good deeds about
watching these movies Thank You Erik
horsemen think recommending these are
way that means a hell of a lot austerity
big thanks also to Mimi M who has shared
some pretty solid resources on our
patreon feed on some various posts okay
we got one more inspect speaking of me
me if this is the same one she is our
most current she's always recommending
rap songs John me only important you
rhyme Mimi's name and she loves you hehe
giggle it with me me yeah drinking up
gonna take a pee but not before I read
read this con me ent boo
I finished Ronny season 2 with muhurta
lolly Allah doing it on HBO there
washing I may destroy you neighbor
totoro Andrey watching the boondocks
and saw the old guard yesterday it was
really fun ok what is she watching you
just are reading her a comment yeah I
wanted to start Romney actually as well
but I'm not gonna start Romney before I
start the boys rehearsal ah I may
destroy you which I've heard is terrific
my neighbor totoro one of the five
Studio Ghibli films on HBO oh we watched
uh we watched the Studio Ghibli movie
Yankees delivery service see there you
go there you go
and re watching the boondocks and Merlin
I believe the the series Merlin saw the
old guard yesterday and it was really
fun
yam everyone's watching the old guard we
gotta watch that and don't worry Olivia
we could watch her ever you want to
watch tonight mm-hmm I'll watch the old
guard in the bedroom watch these bun
crunching action sequences as small as I
can look at all the love you're getting
in this chat for your bars for me me see
the irony is that I can write a decent
line when I can write it keep saying
that John but look you're killing it man
I'm just gonna got the approval if I
count seven people right now dude you're
killing it John dude go watch our first
live remote let's just see if Mimi M can
there's the bars you want Mimi M can
point something out for us too
that's right all eyes on you alright so
who we got here in YouTube's sphere all
right we got Rizzo gaming Rizzo gaming
alright we already rhyme Rizzo game so
this
see what he's gotta say Thank You Rizzo
gaming sir Rizzo gaming's TV viewing
choices have been supernatural Doctor
Who funny
both of those are shows that we watch
over on patreon as well as the boys and
Lucifer great call on the shows you see
yeah Rizzo gaming's choices Doctor Who
and supernatural perfect you guys should
go check some patron and then Lucifer is
really my choices were Umbrella Academy
Doom Patrol of Lucifer which one is
start because I don't like hopping
around shows I'm kind of like a
completionist at times so if I start
like I just gotta get to the end it's
got to get to the end and I also really
got to absorb it so yeah I want I think
I'm probably gonna go on a Doom Patrol
just because of the fact that after I've
doubled Umbrella Academy because that's
just two seasons and that's enough so
then I'm then next I'd probably start up
Lucifer's I hear Lucifer's is incredible
show I'm surprised I'm surprised by that
I was surprised to hear that yeah I
remember when it first came on hearing
the concept seeing the trailer and going
that could be cool but out of this
network and Lucifer's never gonna last
and yeah here we are so I'm actually
pretty intriguing myself yeah okay the
mixed three thank you buddy okay
the mixed three talking to Greg and
Johnny we're gonna go down here read the
super chat loudly for the mixed of this
tricks of what happened when we get John
Wick's that doesn't work that'll work
John Wick's not really I have my
favorite kind of cereal is tricked oh
hey look at that
nah [ __ ] you should have had a real name
it's easier to do yeah I blame you yeah
you're the reason these bars weren't as
fire as they do man come on I did the
horsemen one that was hard
that was hard that was impressive you
know I appreciate that
[Laughter]
yeah to people who never practiced it
and this randomly turned into what we're
gonna do anything we can do it
we got a ya always supporting one
another always growing always everywhere
a loving the [ __ ] out of Lucifer in this
chat yeah what it would it makes the day
you mix the read I've been watching
snowpiercer
Doom Patrol star girl you see that's the
thing people are always asked us to
react to these shows I'm like we can
what is involved we can't react to all
these shows much less watch yeah and the
editing alone like would be difficult
star girl it's another one I've been
hearing incredible things about and it
proved I'm not sexist I should probably
start that up cuz that's how you do it
that's the real way to do it and also
going back decades ago and removing
blackface that's how you do it and
trying to watch as many of the movies
that released some video on demand or to
a streaming service reviewing each
episode of the shows and the movies on
my youtube channel hey you guys should
go check out mix Three's YouTube channel
where he is reviewing each episodes at
the shows and the movies on his channel
hey hey go check him out send him some
love that's what he did he got a
sponsorship subtly sponsored video
recover real clever mix three that's all
you guys that's the secret that's how
you make it in this business
yeah you just pay us to advertise you Oh
Rizzo you're back MCU disney/pixar
hamilton this is the end is this the end
of your own good or comics or this is
the end of the film that you avoid that
might be the end of everything he's
watched so far okay Disney Pixar
Hamilton this I mean that's all you
really need a watch it sounds like
you've been on the Disney Plus app a lot
yeah this is the end doesn't it really
no like totally against everything [ __ ]
I should have started loosing for
everyone's talked about in the chat yeah
man hey Ryan Johnson how's it going hmm
all right so who's yeah [ __ ] there's a
lot of loose Lucifer lover here okay so
who Alana Pico no okay okay okay you can
call me your homeboy Chico as I go out
here to shout out Lana Pico
and judge dreads brother is named Rico
and I once knew a guy named Nico and
some people think I'm a little bit loco
as I try to shout out Lana Pico that
whatever it Ryan doesn't make sense but
rot Lana
weakness to your mama shouts out to
Obama yeah triggered chat starting drama
with her grandmama want to ask everyone
I was she saying okay alright I want to
ask everyone read some of these super
chats or actually I'll read I'll read
them and I'll give you a fun thumb so I
could tell by the change your tone cuz I
can't read it from here I want to ask
everyone to say a prayer for Naya Rivera
sorry to bring the mood down just a
really big fan of hers as for the topic
i binge the zoe kravitz show high
fidelity and I loved it have a good live
stream kisses yeah who's now I feel
terrible
I'm not informed I I heard about this a
couple days ago and apparently she's one
of the main actresses from Glee's where
I knew her best from she's a Hispanic
actress Oh Karla teen actress and yeah
she's been missing as far as the last I
heard was she is been missing they found
her child her 5 year old why like on a
boat or something they found her child
like alone abandoned and they can't find
her and so it's been that's the last
I've heard of it but it's it's sounds
pretty dire and people are hoping for
some type of good news Jesus I don't
know is that I didn't know anything
about that yeah I just sat on that
information I I found it at random on
the Twitter trending when I went to post
one of our other videos like a couple
days Jesus yeah yeah thanks for
mentioning that so yeah sending out
definitely prayers and love for just
some good news there well thank you
thanks I'm glad one of us knew so thank
you and thank you Lana for running that
up now
I'm sure you know who knows a lot about
this probably is Olivia yeah she'll
probably inform me a lot about now and
then what's the second part of her thing
as for the topic I've been to zoe
kravitz show high fidelity and loved it
I haven't seen high fidelity yet I've
heard that's pretty good you didn't like
the movie right I don't really care for
it no I'd be curious about the show I
mean it seems like the kind of thing and
especially if you take the show and
rework it from a female perspective I
feel like you could probably fix some of
the things that don't age very well
about the movie I'd be curious I'm not a
big zoe kravitz fan for whatever reason
so I'm not also a big fan of high
fidelity sex so part of me is sitting
here going maybe I would like the show
you know just for some kind of weird
like opposites thing but uh I guarantee
you maybe it's just the big things
you've seen zoe kravitz in i could yeah
I could see there I could see that being
the case with her for first a lot of
people actually like they don't even
know they're big big things but not
really the smaller projects where she
really gets a chance to actually have a
full-on performance you know okay well
thank you Lana yeah and then oh really
quick okay there's a lot of people in
the chat who have been bringing up
Halloween kills okay and why we didn't
do a reaction to it eh I just thirty
seconds I didn't think it was a real
trailer and I thought it was a trailer
for a trailer because as I watched it
and here's the truth I would look like a
total dumbass if we had recorded
ourselves for Universal who never lets
you monetize any videos by the way so
they were overlooking a real bum ass if
I watched it uh here reacting because I
would have been like wait that's not in
the movie I think in the first movie I
didn't realize this is like new footage
I thought it was like come I forgot how
the exact final moments of the Halloween
like the lines and I thought I think
it's cool that they're picking it up
seconds later
yeah that's really cool other Halloween
movies have done that as well I didn't
realize that that was new footage if I'm
being completely honest it would have
taken me a second to be like oh wait
this is new
because they show the house on fire and
I think that alone kind of puts you in
disoriented are we looking at all
you know it's yeah it's being moments
later it obviously looks everyone looks
the same so he's gonna like what come I
come out but I'm on a gurney there
something yes probably you'll amount of
yeah yeah exactly spider dark in the
chat said it scene looks like a deleted
scene from the first movie so and that
the most I thought if that was it I
didn't know it was like oh this brand
new footage and plus there's nothing to
go off there what would the commentary
be right after the fire this is dead
he's gonna stay dead alright okay who do
we got here we go Caitlin Martinez
alright John give it a shot
Caitlin or Martinez I'm Jake in some
rhymes for Caitlin and I'm not hay in
because of the generosity she's shown to
you and me how about some rhymes fer
Martinez passing it off to you pass me
more Jesus I can do Martinez keep my
head up above the current I got Katelyn
Martinez with the Pez disbands built a
beef fence I'm on defense man okay you
know what here's a ruin dude we're gonna
practice freestyling all week so we can
freestyle on the spot yeah you just wait
guys you just wait really one of the
greatest super Jets I've ever seen that
is a genius that's so funny
Kayla Martinez a dollar ninety-nine
comment twenty dollars really it is the
thought that counts
that's beautiful thank you so much I
don't know what to say
rhymes with Martinez are there's got to
be something Martinez do you guys
have anything in there and in this
livestream what Raisa Martinez Martina
you know Martinez pop star Kleenex chill
level TV welcome back it's good to see
ya
chill level TV watching movies out of
his TP while looking through the TV and
he looks at me and goes hey what's up
Johnny I want to give you a shout-out
because I saw a national treasure and it
was such a pleasure and rewatched the
movie Tron and boy I wish the time had
gone by so much faster cuz when I was
watching Tron with my friend Ron I was
like man this movie is long deaf when I
read a rhymes further your name I'm
gonna just go into what you're super
just saying that's a good hey it worked
for me and Mimi's you know it'll work
for you too
yeah how many national treasure film so
nervous just a - I think and there's a
lot of - Tron films I think so for you
chill level TV those are some good ones
yeah - pair okay so apparently you can
round Martinez with Emilio Estevez
Martinez Martinez Ramirez there you go
that's a natural one Martinez sorry
alright alright okay Oh Louisville TV
princess unicorn nipples and he takes my
balls and doesn't dribble I feel the
ripples of your unicorn nipples ripping
through the atmosphere and we going back
and forth quit clipping or cripples
cripples Danny dibbles in the chat look
at his thumbnail for princess unicorn
looks like I'm watching a guy displaying
his horn as upon watching a dude posing
for porn and he says yo yo thanks
says unicorn nipples yo they're getting
tougher
how does Eminem house I mean I've been
doing this for 25 years you know he's
just all he's got to do all day is just
come up with raps this is damn Jesus
Christ is so hard so hard all right here
we go
oh damn thank you for such a big super
chat do you think Bret Petersen who
can't fret with Brett when he lets out
such a big amount with his check
Peterson misses last thing
Peterson fell in love with Kathryn
Waterston and he showed us his Johnson I
tell you what I'm at it when I'm out of
rhymes I just resort to gave his the
president call him leader son oh that's
the best thing Greg versus Eminem that
[ __ ]
Oh Abbi really I compare getting rap
battle with Eminem like playing the
flash in the injustice games it's like
there's this one moving the injustice
games that flash does where he like hits
you a bunch II you don't see it and then
you're a character who's like if I'm the
character getting hit by the flashes
just go hit a bunch and that's what it's
like with Eminem you get hit so much you
don't even know what he said but it
hurts your feelings Beach he says
looking full look forward to your guys
content every day you just watch Palm
Springs on Hulu this is good very good
movie Andy Samberg was awesome finally
saw inception last night mind-boggling
god bless now it was a mind-boggling
because you were disappointed like
what's the big deal with this movie how
could people love this so much
what is Palm Springs it's a new Andy
Samberg like indie film I don't know who
else is in it but I know it made a
splash at Sundance or one of those big
film festivals it was like one of the
major talks and now it's finally
starting to come out I think on VOD oh
damn so I don't know much about the plot
but I've heard good things in the past
week I love Andy Samberg he's given one
of the least funny college commencement
speeches really what was he trying to do
just to take people in here
he was clearly going for jokes and it
wasn't funny I don't even know if he's
tried since then but I love watching
comedians give College commencement
speeches are usually inspiring and funny
his was not funny
Oh was it inspired I love how I asked
what Palm Springs isn't someone threw
spider dagger than Jeff it's a place
correct yeah get over yourself quick
Jesus there's also a petition going for
me to see interstellar which I have oh
so you're already in luck Wow
you know this this topic you normally
normally lately I've been great with the
topics I come with the topic and we keep
the topic going all day until like the
last 20 minutes and suddenly it goes off
the rails this has gone off the rails
since since the first five minutes I
mean take it back I saw part of
Excalibur the other day have you ever
seen yeah man with Arthur Arthur Fleck
movie and and Harry gnarl Harry Hamlin
that's like you're talking about like
the old one right the super trippy one
live-action r-rated yeah they're like
expressionistic one and I saw when I was
a kid yeah that's a long time [ __ ] up
movie I saw when I was a kid soon dan
was [ __ ] up like the dudes like
banging the the chick at the beginning
of the movie then there was like a bunch
of blood [ __ ] up movie yeah and then
Helen Mirren and she's all conniving and
yeah Jesus Christ yeah I've also been
watching a lot of tik-tok videos I don't
have a tick-tock never will maybe after
tonight we'll see but thanks Bret
Petersen Peter Pacheco she oh oh
girlfriend she girlfriend will probably
watch umbrella
thank you Peter Pacheco Umbrella Academy
again for season 2 and watch the boys
again John your laps are as bad as your
Portuguese Wow I don't care if you said
JK
alright we're Google in a Portuguese
accent right we're trying our best
because if I get a good Portuguese
accent that means my raps are good
solving problems all right I'll take too
much time you know
maybe we could just get better around we
should have brought the fan in here yeah
maybe I'll go get the fan do I need to
watch room 104 what is that I don't know
I got a question for the chat can we
take this off for a second we'll go back
to the super chest in just a bit I got a
question for the chat what do you guys
think about the Russo brothers saying
that Wolverine shouldn't come in for a
while what do you think John do you
think I'm trying to make this livestream
relevant and topical with Wolverine like
in Phase two
no I think they should definitely wait a
while I would I'll do yeah it's been a
few years John I know but like the
attention span is so low like I want
there to be like a solid I don't know
like the rumor mill is beginning and we
have the point where now we can start
introducing x-men and mutants and
everything and I feel like I still at
the outset of this want to build up to
Wolverine I guess I don't want him to be
the first wave of the x-men presence we
get because Hugh Jackman has been so
iconic and Logan is still a great movie
that is still like running on TV and
still holds the eff up but when I watch
other Hugh Jackman movies that have come
out since Logan I don't think about
Logan Wolverine anymore come on I mean
and those other movies are hits like
like the greatest showman but was that
before after Logan I think it was like
the first thing after Logan yeah he's
fine and then he's done other things
like that one political movie yeah bad
education
I'll try this off I agree with that
they're trying throw us off you'll see
you'll see he's gonna show up he will
show up in the next Black Widow movie
LeBron weren't they talking about
casting him though for like this phase
were they talking about trying to find
if they're worrying right now I'm not
sure I love this this this is a love I
love all the cops are coming in here
right now all right let's get back on
track what do you got John
I just I'm getting some advice from the
chat on how to do a proper brewskis
accent which is apparently try space
but with moorish inflections and russian
sounding a bit look what you set up the
stream for i am gonna take that it's
already chaos you're you've just made it
worse now because you really want to
learn how where you going oh sorry I
thought it would be a good time to maybe
check back in with the there's okay
let's just let's go back here okay we're
back at the super Jasper I will get the
fan eventually and I can see we're both
sweating a lot it's totally a minute
before you guys can really see how much
we're give it some time you'll see it
don't worry alright John here we go here
we go Landon Smith Landon
hanging out with Michael Gambon and yeah
he'd be hitting the landing cuz his name
be Landon Smith I'll [ __ ] around Smith
Smith don't be a [ __ ] it doesn't work
John don't turn to the dark side and
become a Sith oh there we go but I be
grabbing on the balls of Landon and then
I go down and I'm looking at Landon and
I see that he's the ultimate part of a
fandom landing grander than the Grand
Canyon oh the best companion when you oh
that's a great one this is like junior I
guess learning yeah man this is the
pride you go in like a 1 bar is enough
yeah you don't need a whole five minutes
were all rhymes might be random but
nothing like when talking about Landon
hey guys awesome performances in the
inner geekdom tournament thank you
guys John's match just went up this week
and you're only as good as your last
performance yes I easily the least good
of the four it was fantastic also John
watch the boys you see that John you see
what happens when I get the reject all
right you're gonna see me on Monday
morning and a boys t-shirt like I just
watched the first season four time
and I read all the comic opera tits
season 2 that's great John why haven't
you watched [ __ ] all of better call
Saul oh yeah I'll be I will be an expert
on all of TV pretty fast yes and I won't
sleep Landon I appreciate the super chat
and I appreciate so much that you
compliment us on our Schmo down match
yeah I appreciate it
Parks and Rec I haven't finished that
show yet I couldn't get through that
final season it just wasn't doing it for
me and I really just give up on a show
and there's always a moment in my life
where I'm like guy you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna finally finish up just
like these rides
Amy's in the chat encouraging you to try
some new flows out what new flows I got
one flow and I'm working right off
there's a reason Vanilla Ice is still
doing concerts when there's a quarantine
on also John watch the boys hell yeah
thank you I will I have I've already
watched the boys during this live show
all right okay well thank you buddy
t-mac t-mac about to spit some lack
opinions
Hamilton is butt juice Oh throwing she
going shade at my man lin-manuel Miranda
hey I can't I don't know how to do that
he's got the the a that like I rep down
buttery in the 90s yeah mm at least
there's a double toasted vid where
they're talking about it they pulled up
a clip of him on Sesame Street
he's freestyling the problem is they're
he's rapping and the thing is like it's
clear that he's vibin and like his is
he's on rhythm and his vibe is good but
yeah he's just got that kind of like
high-pitched thing that yeah I don't
know how to do it it's so funny I love
the almost a sensual because my voice is
high
like I can't imagine him doing like a
really hard tough rap all right oh okay
the nice Nisa first name Aneesa the last
name a live one day John Humphrys gonna
do yeah he's gonna go down to the gas
station and pump you full of you know
bread your mom is watching I got a new
lease on life okay okay
Aneesa I live uh getting some failed
rhymes from Greg Alba generous giver
whoa why'd you interrupt me I was
flowing I'm sorry I didn't realize you
were trying a new flow you what the [ __ ]
I'm sorry I'll open this beer while you
while you arrived look look if you're
not appreciating these super chats you
can you might want to find a different
lives to find a whole new fandom the
fact that it's annoying some people
who's only gonna make me want to do it
more
Andy so what do you say hey guys had a
long day Olivia Aneesa Olivia
sometimes I read her name as Olivia and
sometimes look at it as Bolivia
hey guys had a long day we were so busy
today so it's nice to come home watch
y'all and relax then do it all again
tomorrow
ah nice I'm sorry that's as long I heard
you were from 7:00 a.m. to 7:00 p.m.
dude that's that's 24 hours no way the
mathjax good
that's either way though like a 12
straight you know in your situation I
can't even imagine the amount of wear
with urgency room trying to patrol the
doom and she wants John so you can be
her groom
thoughts that loan from the cradle to
the tomb here the problem is we start
flowing you differ like not even flowing
but like thinking we are we look at each
other for approval yeah that's the
problem we can't be doing that anymore
well maybe we just needed to like trade
off bars you know like when you get a
couple in that's Shirl and then you know
and then the only trouble were run into
is if you had like a great problem was I
really so live and she's okay with the
sax joke so I wanted a rhyme her name
with vagina but then I didn't want to do
it for fear of vagina that's true any
hope moving on here Michael Swift has a
cool name Michael Swift what a gift to
mankind you're doing you're looking live
we know Michael Swift going to the shop
thrift go on datpiff and download his
mixtape watches the movie Tokyo Drift
get some lift because a cult picked up
his app went on lyft picked up his app
when I lift dam okay alright I needed a
ride Craig's Hamilton and another
youniverse goddamn straight Miranda I've
been catching up on the on the Hannibal
TV show I hear they're doing season
before don't get too excited buddy
we don't know for sure if they're doing
season four and I think the reason why
is because CBS has picked up a Clarice
Starling show that's supposed to take
place right after Silence of the Lambs I
think like after sunset lambs but before
Hannibal right I think that's the thing
so they wanted to use season four of
Hannibal so they could precipitous
Starling into the show but I don't think
it's gonna happen because of that fact
and if they can't do it if they can't do
it do Clarice I don't think they'll
wanna do season four it's just plain and
simple yeah if that was their plan yeah
exactly exactly exactly glad you caught
the stream ax - yeah
and then yeah okay oh hey guys - Katy
Orlando's question the murse for the
real rejects is it Spreadshirt comms
like we were that show all the time
these eggs
there are nipple chills t-shirts and I
will make a graphic to share what's so
funny is my girlfriend will go to go to
workout or just go to the store and show
where the nipple chill shirt it's funny
cuz you're my girlfriend but no mouse in
the world this is a reason why no woman
ever buys the nipple chill shirt from
the real rejects okay I know might be
the first we need a different company
that provides more comfort with the
actual fabric of the shirts that we
provide man if we could get some like
super soft I'll know hey the one I have
the maroon real rejects Devil's Rejects
design by Greg's sister that I have as a
t-shirt is actually a piece off so
that's nice yeah so maybe it maybe you
got to order like an off color so let's
see here
Oh Eric horseman thank you again buddy
yeah two in a row look out
Eric was here but you can't have any
fear because he's always going to endear
with some super chats right around the
corner the near he's up watching Doctor
Who and do Torchwood bring on the Hat
hey I would like to see torch we want to
start Torchwood I think it would be a
little too much to handle on patreon but
I am very curious to see it sounds like
a lot it's the kind of thing that I
would be interested in watching
alongside Doctor Who but I would want to
do in a way where if I fall behind it's
ok but I've heard that if you watch I
mean like this is anyone like actually
love Torchwood not as much as Doctor Who
from what I can tell although it seemed
like Eric maybe prefers Torchwood really
alright perhaps maybe for you Eric all
these consider it there you go
my consideration that goes a long way
cuz you never know I might actually
consider enough to do it yeah what I was
in there I've learned the Kevin Feige
way of a handling reaction requests is
I'll consider it because a lot of times
when I say that I end up doing it and
then sometimes I don't say yeah I need
to finish the clone war so Jin Choi in
the chat I definitely do need to finish
it but yeah Torchwood is something I do
news I would like to watch it but I'd
like to get off at least halfway through
doctor who first all right Eric horseman
shout out to my LGBTQ love Victor on
Hulu is a worthy sequel to love Simon
too cute really I haven't heard much
about love Victor I've really wanted to
watch that show because love Simon I'm
actually surprised it got a show because
I didn't know love Simon was a big
enough hit to have got in a show for
Hulu yeah I mean yeah it's one of those
things where I'm a little surprised but
at the same time I do remember it kind
of taking the culture by storm for a hot
minute when it came out even though I
I'm actually like it's it's kind of
hardening to hear that from from you
especially because you are a part of the
LGBTQ community and I've heard some
complaints about the first film you know
just in terms of being very simplified
for the mass straight audience but but
yeah if the sequel is good I'd love to
check it out I'm not sure I what's I
loved I I really did love that movie
love Simon a lot we saw it on I saw it
on did you watch it yeah I saw it on the
pub annex to Mexico and I was like
having to contain my laughter because I
don't want an anointing one and I was
having to contain my tears when I was
watching though Simon and to be honest
with you Eric I appreciate all this
super chats here I would say that I'm
more likely to start love Victor than I
am to start Torchwood sometime soon
may God bless you for all your sins John
Wow okay now it's obnoxious
cut it out this is getting ridiculous
I'm sorry I'm sorry everyone and then
hit man Hudson says wait I thought Greg
Olivia and John
we're in a throuple was I mistaken
Olivia would never go for John
especially not today she's the one woman
in this world
who would not go for John cool and
that's why she's my girlfriend because
they admitted John was also every other
girl was like you I met John first who
knows what could have happened and then
aleeah's Oh No Oh God
one time I mentioned John and she
vomited so you know I'm just saying
that's always what I hope for I wanted a
reaction atopy well you weirdly get on
like weirdly get off on it yeah I do
because like you're uncomfortable boners
that happen you're allowed you're making
people like forfeit their lunch like
that's money right there like that's a
real reaction you could take the bank by
Landon Smith I hope you enjoyed your
shoutout yes nah man nah that's that no
John doesn't joke we are not a threat
it's never gonna happen and sorry Eric
horsemen LGBTQ I plus there you go what
Oh Eric there's more letters yes
although it seems to be where the plus
goes seems to flux
I see the LGBTQ I mean II don't even
notice it oh look out screaming shout
don't get that clout chasing up the yeah
I don't have Corona but if I did I would
ask you what to do yeah the plus moves
around but I yeah there are a lot of
letters in the acronym pretty soon
they're gonna have the whole outfit well
I I do I am curious as somebody who
isn't you know as well-versed on this I
mean LGBT was the start of what I was
understanding that LGBTQ and then LGBTQI
and and LGBTQ I plus there's more letter
and then there's also LGBTI a so yeah
that I feel like where the plus goes is
always kind of fluxes oh okay and I
don't know if there's like a rigidity to
when you do that or not but
room 105 is a great TV show each episode
has different cast that is shot in a
motel we're gonna give under some a
little bit of undivided attention really
quick to just what's going on and you're
in the John help me out I gotcha I'll do
with my left hand oh my god you're so
sexy look at the chat right now soon all
you guys are saying in the chat never
fight a man with a perm okay so so Jin
choy is saying in the chat that the only
movie he's seen during lockdown mmm this
entire time during lockdown is only God
forgives why did you choose cause it's
that because it's that slow running it
out I've been watching it a 1/5 of the
pace wow that is so funny
only God forgives is the only one you've
seen this whole time I'm sorry
like I love Ryan I love Ryan Gosling
everyone knows me knows I love Ryan
Gosling but if that's the only one
you've seen this whole time I'm sorry
and then let's see here okay what are
you doing you're texting yeah what are
you well yeah because somebody who
wanted to be here shot me a message
shows we like Erica Oh Erica really
she's great okay watch stranger things
over quarantine now I see that that's
the kind of she you see what's funny is
well like from our own channel just from
looking at certain numbers what I've
seen go up in view count for us has not
been like comic book related [ __ ] it's
actually been like covering like scary
things on the internet or something like
that right yeah scary ghost videos and I
thought it would be the last thing that
would I thought people would look for
life a weird sense of escapism through
like comedic factors or whatever but the
hearing some people I catch up on only
God forgives I mean stranger things
actually makes a lot of sense but Oh
food Wars animes on Netflix
have you heard of this cooking show not
know the cookie
what's there's this cooking game I just
learned about kitchen kitchen sub I mean
I feel like someone in the chat will
know about but here it really raises
your anxiety for it
oh god that no there are already like
cooking shows already do that but it's
like a calm game you have to partner up
with someone and say this is weird it's
like a video game like a cooking video
game oh no I don't know anything you'd
really get a kick out of it I would love
that I am I like out-of-the-box video
game I got to finish the Witcher I agree
with you Daniel Travis t-mac I showed my
girlfriend the MS for the first time and
she's still mad I don't blame the ending
we'll do that later yeah yeah we'll do
that to you I like the ending but I yeah
it makes people mad it's legit this
weird is like I watched the ending for I
see the ending for the mist and I go I
don't like that ending I really don't
mm-hmm
I watched it and it got me mad and I
never got oh and I never like warmed up
to the way they chose to end it I
watched the ending for The Sopranos an
ending that obviously pissed off a lot
of people mm-hmm and then when I when I
first watched it my first reaction was
that's annoying but then when I was like
really talking about it I'm like that's
brilliant
so I've like really loved they both have
these endings that are so divisive but
the mist never came around to me warming
up to it but Sopranos I've really warmed
up - hell yeah at least 100 - not bad
hello Luke Cromwell that is your
shoutout is it Kitchen Nightmares I
think it's Kitchen Nightmares yeah with
gore cooking ma it's it's one of those
what do you guys are [ __ ] saying it
cutthroat kitchen or cook it's no it's
it's definitely one of the it's other
cooking mom or a cutthroat kitchen wait
a minute is cut cut through okay okay so
cook Kitchen Nightmares is is with like
Gordon Ramsay dimers is an actual
television show cutthroat kitchen or
cooking mama is one it's probably
cooking because cutthroat kitchen is
also a TV show with Elton Brand I think
it's Cooking Mama and I want her to try
that out cooking mom yes
unless yes yes yes yeah that's it yeah
the unauthorized addition I wanted to
try that game out I hear you like you
work with someone but I really can bring
out the anxiety oh yeah let's do it
apparently Aneesa and I are names and
uncle and Eric and Rizzo gaming or a
niece and nephew oh cool all right
yeah I need a watch aren't cup gin some
Netflix Netflix now we have no excuse
collectively yeah maybe you should start
watching the boys I should I start
watching the boys I've had this weird
inkling when I oughta start watching the
boys but I don't know where it's coming
from what we might am I thinking of the
wrong thing then because I'm hearing
it's not a beer maybe sound a video game
there's a game you can play who are you
like where you can work with someone
yeah I forgot the name of it I need to
find you out I'm sorry no it does not
sound insane this is crazy man i weirdly
haven't been can I shouldn't have called
this movies and shows who've been
watching during quarantine because I
feel like I've been catching up on like
video games YouTube channels a whole
bunch of stuff that is not really video
games and movies I've restrung a few
guitars I've listened to so many
podcasts than I ever have I've only been
in a podcast before when they're funny
mmm or like Loveline words like
relationships and sex and then lately
I'm like I'm actually like really
enjoying the Tom Seguros podcast and Joe
Rogan's podcast you know I hear Joe
Rogan is great there's a great guy keeps
telling me yes yes not problematic in
the least Giroux but yeah some movies
and shows that are coming to mind right
now I mean I uh I started community oh
really what I started community what do
you think it wasn't a big fan I'm gonna
continue it to see when it as I hear it
changes up a lot of every season but one
that I've really I only watched the
first two episodes years ago and now I'm
like eight episodes in and I feel
terrible about saying this because this
is a show this is one of those shows
that everyone has told me you'll love
Greg
you'll love own you'll love this show
and not a lot of times I feel like
people get that wrong with me
especially when it's a comedy show yeah
I don't often find the [ __ ] funny that
people assume all fine funny yeah in
terms of a show format Rick and Morty oh
nice it's such a funny it's such a
creative funny joke so only on the first
season I'm really what that is a really
inventive and hilarious television show
yeah Rick and Rick and Morty from me
rides a line that I really appreciate
where it is like irreverent and crazy
but it's also especially the further you
get it's very much invested in its
sci-fi and it's also very much invested
in its character development it's like a
morning allistic Bojack horseman to me
yeah you know in some ways it's it
overcook the game that I'm thinking
surveys says over on Stevie this one ooh
ghost town is a design I've been
catching up on YouTube apology videos
i'ma catch them on my Shane Dawson I've
been watching all jennamarbles videos
people be apologizing on YouTube Holly
thanks for just becoming a sub preciate
it
oh yeah some people are trying to beat
themselves to the punch there's a lot of
[ __ ] people out there who are like
I'm gonna get cancelled I'm around I'm
right around the corner oh I saw just
call myself out right that's the right
thing to do and then they like some
people like [ __ ] up their apology guys I
would like to apologize for anything I
might do in the future like not watching
the boys and the boys
I don't like TV or any of this stuff we
talk and in the middle of YouTube people
doing that I instead decide to do Disney
buys the rights to the Bible to do what
everyone else is the boy over the
quartering loved it play the hits I've
heard good things about that show dark
let's catch up on some of our super
chats here but I love everything either
Sam
History X oh that's a that's a movie
there is no consistency here to what
everyone has been telling us they've
been catching up on there's not a single
consistency oh thank you Joe thank you
Joe Sandesh
Sandy's samdasoo for for subbing for
joining us
sorry I don't know why I chose to speak
that way should we do super chat or
sorry I did not mean to speak that way
yeah see the YouTube super chat okay
let's do that let's get super yeah it's
get super who we got next we got uh
aneesa's back Aneesa ah Aneesa Oh John
every guy's hurt John's awesome Southern
drawl and my southern dandy Aneesa
she says John's speak to me in y'all
southern accent
don't look at me AXA speak to me in that
sweet drawl
let me believe that your voice is
molasses rolling down my eardrums into
my cerebellum that's for you we lost 10
viewers I'm sorry I didn't mean to do
that voice well thank you and nice and
Bret Petersen back in the chat again
thank you dear BP we keep you moving PS
don't watch inception hi haha I think if
you watch inception hi the second time
it can be fun and you could pick up on
deeper things and appreciate the visuals
even more and then the third time you
watch it wash it piss-drunk
you'll pass out early mhm and then the
fourth time take some Advil doesn't do
anything oh you never know oh [ __ ]
they're already talking to each other
already talking to a cow behind are we
on these super chats we're okay so this
is 548 653 so we are an hour behind we
know we need us hurry through this
Horseman says
hey Aneesa - which Aneesa says I saw
American Graffiti at the drive-in and it
was okay
what Aneesa you didn't like uh you
didn't like I mean I appreciate what you
contributing Eric Horseman John often
forget to thank you guys thank you very
much but I am white thank you
I saw American Graffiti at the drive I'm
sorry they're like American Graffiti I
love that's one of my top 10 favorite
movies but also Olivia didn't love it as
much as I hoped either so we don't talk
about it we say maybe it's maybe it's
more of a man's movie I don't think so I
wouldn't peg it that way I know who made
it
yeah George Lucas do you know who
starred in it yeah Mickey Rooney and
Harrison Ford and ladies oh no no no I'm
sorry a UH Ron Howard there similarly
Rooney's Breakfast at Tiffany's yeah yes
his iconic turn in Breakfast I'm now
convinced John watches Django Unchained
every day I is the only Tarantino film I
know that in grindhouse I have teachers
didn't I Pro 24 thanks for being here I
do I watched Django every day it's a lot
of work Percy in the chat saying I would
like to apologize for not watching these
apology videos I was a different person
started coming out I have to hold myself
accountable and really do my part by
watching the videos it's a semi-hard for
the Avengers game it fluctuates for me
to be honest I'm gonna I'm gonna
personally cancel you Percy Aneesa
saying hi Erik how are you you guys can
talk to each other you don't have to do
this here - is Erik response Thank You
Erik very much for responding
I've okay Anissa hope you are doing
amazing had my first ever panic attack
last week and ended up in the emergency
room what coulda sworn it was a heart
attack
I know I know about this air it's always
what I was talking about in your recent
shoutout this oh my dude Erik I highly
recommend
you'll enjoy it you'll love hi
I think Erik
would love therapy if you find the
therapist who really lives with you and
who will like who knows your frequency
and will let you go off on a tangent I
feel like you could get a lot done and
also enjoy dude you out of a good I
think a booth Anissa and Eric would love
it for two very different reasons and I
feel like Eric would genuinely love
therapy
yeah and then when he gets mad at
therapist you leave that therapist to
find a new therapist and that's the way
you do yeah and you don't work through
it just move on I've never made it past
a third session and I am occupied I've
seen 30 therapists I am gonna do it I'm
doing what you're supposed to do let's
see here oh no I haven't watched
justified John Aldridge but I love
Timothy Olyphant so I will
Dominique's a fairy only on the
Freestyle shoutouts [ __ ] we haven't been
doing those pretty solid shot my name is
France
is f is f feed DS f ET ok ok so fitti
doing my work on the graffiti while I
write in the name and Dominic za fede
and sometimes I get a little bit greedy
yeah and then I get a little bit needy
when I seize Afridi sending us these
chats I get weepy when I ran out of
things to say to cap off his freestyle
so I replenish my energy with the
sandwich made a PB that's like a and J
yeah there we go
yeah why'd you retract a message Erik
what you say here Erik it's unacceptable
I don't know if it's [ __ ] up Erik
don't don't leave of all people you
should not be you're on the record man
always but Dominick thank you so much
dude that's really sweet of you I think
so much Daniel Travis alright so ok 6:57
p.m. we are exactly one hour behind on
the super chance we will catch up whoo
Daniel Travis Thank You Daniel the man
who'll do some Daniel Travis Travis all
right go for it John I did most of the
other one
Daniel the manual read the manual cuz
then you'll know how [ __ ] works
Travis don't leave house without your
canvas so that you can paint Daniels
don't taint the impression you've made I
don't - my favorite anime Thank You
Daniel Travis you got good names that
are hard to rhyme without turning them
into Dan or trav
my favorite anime is Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood that shows really
dark and light hearted that is a
terrific show I'm gonna shamelessly plug
I reacted to the whole thing over on
patreon but yeah that's a terrific show
and that's a great quarantine show too
because it's one of those anime series
that's longer but that is contained
still so yeah it's flippin great I even
though I will never recommend you a TV
show because I am behind on so many
especially one especially one in
particular called the points on Amazon
Prime I think Full Metal Alchemist is
one that sometime between now and when
you're dead you might be enjoyable to
check out all right cool hey Joel hey
Joel full metal forever selfie cam being
a Travis Alto volt alia oh god your
guys's names is that voltage voltage
evil tie a volt are ya
Aalto out in the snow like Balto
traveling a Paulo Rialto I love it
that's great
get out ho boat ah hey volt I am Not
sure honestly what do we say with Aldo
volt all hey and I just pray that I'm
pronouncing your name the right way haha
thank you wait
made you crap your pants in the theaters
theater I told my girlfriend it
I've never crapped my pants the theatres
but so my girlfriend a true story the
other day I told her a true story that
happened to me in it was second grade
and I was like yeah one time in second
grade I like [ __ ] my pants I was like
too nervous to ask to go to the bathroom
and I just went the whole day and
everyone was making fun of me because
we're like Greg smells like poo then I
took a car ride home my brother dad were
like it smells like [ __ ] in this car and
I just like know I vomit I just kept
saying I didn't like it to cover it up
like no I followed it on myself and then
I just told my girlfriend us whole story
and then she said I love you then I went
over to this live stream and then I told
you guys why don't you guys feel for me
it's embarrassing sometimes kids [ __ ]
their pants act like you've been there
yeah sometimes adults [ __ ] their pants
that happens no we don't it's cool it's
not just like in that Adam Sandler movie
it's cool rizo gaming is back oh really
where horseman do we offend him he
retracted a comment and now I'm worried
Oh Eric I can't keep offending our
comment with a super chat if you're not
offensive just come to the regular chat
just just really quick to dalton Smith a
heavily heavily prefer Rocket Man to
Bohemian Rhapsody every day of the week
including Monday Rizzo gaming thank you
my darling we love you and also great
work moderating what our patreon discord
yes thank you
Ryan can me Eric and Greg join me you
which is me and Aneesa at the gas
station I mean I'm fine with it
but I think it's up to Anissa oh really
yeah you got it the more the merrier
gosh going to the gas station to watch
John Aneesa
relations that's what he thinks about
during his action of masturbation
listening to station-to-station
this is what we're thinking about in the
state of our nation John I'll be patient
at the gas station no contemplation I
hope we can all be there I hope it could
be a giant gathering hits people great
to watch John and Anissa at the gas
station oh thank God it's not offended I
can't go through this again but thank
you
legendary Dead Eye legend wait for it
dary magical like hairy scary to the
bone
why what what Dead Eye taking the red
eyes and you cannot D die that John
occasionally lies I do everybody I live
twice a week yeah I get Thursdays and
Fridays to tell a lie can't afford a day
an afternoon why on a Friday an amazing
movie sad it couldn't be in the theaters
oh I didn't realize Greyhound was coming
out until this week yeah they moved it
to act and I'm surprised it in a way I
feel like that movie would would have
had a chance that when theaters reopened
that people will be excited for it yeah
one okay this might sound like a weird
thing I don't even know if it sounds
[ __ ] up so let's give it a shot and
say it publicly is that Tom Hanks was
like one of the but like him and Idris
Elba were like the first two big celebs
to get the coronavirus right yeah and as
I feel like people might be in support
it was like oh [ __ ] now that we're open
let's go watch that Tom Hanks movie you
know instead of opening with Tennant
they should have reopened with great has
just to be like support Tom hey
important in America than Tom Hanks and
then now and I also have heard really
great things about greyhound and it just
but then there's this other flip side of
me is that a lot of times these video
on-demand movies that have been coming
out movies that we're supposed to come
out in theaters then get released some
video on demand a lot of my personal
reaction to them has been looks like
this should have been on video on demand
in the first place you know what I mean
and Greyhound seems to be the first one
that is kind of moved like the first big
theater release it's kind of moved to
video on demand that seems like people
would have really have really have
enjoyed this one in theaters I could see
that the only thing I think that maybe
cuts down on that for me as I've heard
that it isn't as action heavy as the
trailer makes it look what a bunch of
[ __ ] which you know was totally
unexpected ooh
okay hold on remind me of his charms
common because I want to tell her we
almost did a video about it but then
obviously did not yes thank you
legendary dad I appreciate it man yeah
aneesa's back
rizo gaming sorry it's only going to be
John and I oh thanks for the same
chatter nice up like a nice r1 some
private time all right bye honey
Anissa makes the rules why are you guys
going to a gas station to do it I don't
know Greg why are we going to a gas
station you can at least rent like a
crappy motel or an air B&B there be no
crappy motels dilation [ __ ] it does this
is a hit yes you want to be looking for
that room as last-minute as possible and
you don't want to get a room on your
first try you want to get it travel to
three or four motels before you take her
to France
oh yeah like Mickey and Jake in that
episode of Doctor Who do we just watch I
really I really think I'm doing my
leaking news character I really think
that you can go to end up in a
relationship with a nice um one day I'm
calling her right here right now
pressures on I'm saying telling you
right now
you feel pressured alright then I want
to go back to here to talk about a
question that Hashem has asked in the
chat because this is a very very
interesting topic to me but Deadeye
6-1-6 is that a different Deadeye or the
same there's legendary Deadeye there's
Deadeye 6-1-6
oh it's it they're from alternate
timelines who likes to eat Chinese
pick-up sticks it doesn't suck dicks
he's a pimp he's like look at my tricks
stacking fat bricks and he likes to take
his lollipop and licks lays down that
oil slick hit you with a stick thank you
buddy
thank you for us to protect got sucked
into Chernobyl the best miniseries in
history
next to Band of Brothers Chernobyl is I
thought Chernobyl is one of the greatest
things ever and I do need it why you
know what that should be the top thing i
watch but it's only six episodes i
really always want to catch up on the
superhero stuff because let's face when
one of those trailers comes out those do
the best that's why i'm like i should
probably catch up on my superhero who
shows you and that's what I've been
doing except for agents of shield oh hey
Jenna
welcome Jenna's in the chat hell yeah oh
yeah except for agents of shield which I
am NOT going to give you Chris anis is
not the hidden in quitte type you know I
was just joking oh of course you could
end up in a relationship yeah I'm [ __ ]
thinks so highly of you and Nisa no I
mean the gas station is what I do I make
a dumb joke the colony so we're getting
bound for life at the gas station
legally we're getting married at the gas
station I've been so jealous of the
attention and nice has been given Jon
this whole time oh and I'm the one who
tries talking with the nice and having
these private conversations with her and
then somehow she always just wants to
get to you and I'm sorry for taking that
out on you and Nisa
can you apologize to Anissa form sorry
and the size means to create the
situation and to you know cause all this
strife hard we went to Texas I have a
serious question
oh if we went to Texas yes and we got it
you and I got like we took a little trip
we got like an Airbnb or a hotel or
something and if and then we're out with
Aneesa would you would you go out on a
date with Aneesa I put you on the spot
here
I don't know I guess I it would be hard
to quantify because I mean we have like
a pre-existing know each other so like
we'll be hanging out yes she's the one
subscriber I hope you actually date okay
dueling I'll go with air of course yes I
need says no interest in ever getting to
know me only to get to you that's the
aneesa's is a lovely human being so I
would be lucky
Erik horsemen now if anyone's a hit it
and quit it kind of guy it's Erik very
least quit we'll discuss today is just
offensive jokes from here on do have
kids though that's true I've Ryan and
Erik speaking of I'm their Rizzo gaming
/ Anissa lol I guess at least Eric is
coming to the gas station yeah what we
did notice you Jenna we said hi Jenna we
just called you out all right so where
are we at
we are senpai and we notice you we're
not what what's this one Percy Percy
Tremblant
let's read it oh no we got a freestyle
Percy tremble it that's a challenge
trembling I mean you got it a shot loot
I breathe I feel like you can pull it
off do you have a template of things
that rhyme with trembling I'm trembling
over
here trying to think of a rhyme for
Percy lord have mercy
tersely i think of these rhymes disperse
me so that I can go think with relaxed
mind tremble it gimlet
it's very good job yeah I believe in you
I believe hey guys first I'm super
chatting big fan oh thank you so much I
mean I appreciate you taking the plunge
with us I recently watched the dead
don't die with Bill Murray great zombie
flick flick very self-aware a series of
ASCII expressions at least one is a
devil thumb or a devil horns
I like the dead don't die I know it's
kind of got a lot of mixed reviews but I
yeah I really enjoy that it's now it's
very dry and I can understand a lot of
the complaints about it but the cast is
great and if you're on the movies
wavelength it's very enjoyable what the
hell is the dead don't die it's that
like I feel like I should know what that
is yeah it's the Jim Jarmusch's jambe
movie with Adam driver and Bill Murray
and till the Swinton and Adam driver and
Bill Murray or cops and I want to say
it's Chloe's 7 no no until the Swinson
well tell us Witten yeah but Chloe
Sevigny is also in it and a few other
people Jenna any help ok
well dude Percy tremble it let's see
here Percy don't try to show me any
mercy because sometimes I feel like I
get a little bit weary when I try to
think of something to say it might be
Tremblay Jacob Tremblay we could be
trembling could be Tremblay Tremblay
what'd you say I said friend let's see
you could go with Tremblay I'm gonna try
trembling but Percy tremble it you
cannot forget dad ok I never want to
forget my man named Percy Tremblay
because every once in a while I might
shoot into the hoop and hit the net but
one thing I'll do is get your [ __ ] wet
non-drug Maria Hammond but we're getting
there uh-huh
Oh buddy Eric horseman is back in areas
hi Olivia hi Olivia if Olivia's still
following along at home
ie in the next room thank you Eric
awesome Horstman love oh my god you
never forget was her than that would
Brett Brett Brett looking like Boba Fett
shouting like James Hetfield Peterson
keeping an eye had a kid and he was my
weary son and I named him Bret Peters
son and he's like the old man with a gun
yeah and Bret Peters son has a weird
attraction to priests and nuns
wow what a major super chat thank you
dude that's a really big super chat oh
my god thank you should take this more
seriously Ben had the itch to rewatch
the amazing spider-man movie Andrew
Garfield was an underrated spider-man
and actor for you I still think he is an
underrated actor for sure
and Andrew Garfield in the amazing
spider-man
I like the amazing spider-man one a lot
of people don't I do
I still think amazing spider-man 2 is
the worst spider-man movie ever made
then I would say spider-man 3 but for me
it's easily me I've tried watching you
know I watched me experiments you know
like I didn't care for it I'll give it a
shot
eventually I gave it another shot down
the road I was like not easily still the
worst one 100% I don't care as much for
those movies although I think the
amazing spider-man the first one is
pretty decent but yeah I liked Andrew
Garfield a lot and I think that he got
slagged a bit more than he ought to have
just because his like I understand that
Peter Parker is supposed to be a bit
more of a dweeb but I liked his take on
the character honestly
all right I don't dislike his portrayal
now I really want to talk super quick
about this Batman Forever thing okay
alright sit somewhere - Batman sure I
figured it's appropriate that I could
talk about this of course
so only when you were only when I'm
wearing a Batman shirt obviously so
there's this thing that's going out
apparently someone from Warner Brothers
confirm this oh boy that there's a
three-hour cut of Batman Forever hmm and
oh for a split second I was like are
people gonna be like petitioning to have
this release and I'm sure there are I
made a joke we made a joke about the
Last of Us to getting remade what
there's a petition like I didn't even
know this so basically they there's this
cut that Joel Schumacher has a
three-hour cut and it's been confirmed
and there's this whole thing where he's
not Batman anymore like he he goes to
this like memory loss and he forgets
that he's Batman
it's like a whole hour missing from that
movie because the movies already two
hours and nine minutes pretty long oh
wow I forget that it's that long and
here's the thing with Batman Forever why
I personally don't want a extended cut
of that movie because I heard of him he
was very pretty [ __ ] annoying but the
one thing about it was there was not one
bit of me that was watching it going if
it had more time it could have been
better there's like never a single
thought in my brain of that because for
the most part it seems to flow you know
for what it is it float like Suicide
Squad that's an obvious example of if
this movie had more breath and wasn't
edited the way it is it could be a
better movie Batman V Superman you could
get the impression like that feel
there's something missing from here
Batman Forever does not I've seen
realizing and I'm just like I don't want
more of this hard to face I don't want
more Jim Carrey this just seems like it
would be more annoying with what the
style is that Joel Schumacher has
provided for those two films so
personally
I
no interest in that coming out and if
Vig did come out I probably never watch
it not out of like you hate or taking a
stance I just have zero interest in it
and I feel like I have pretty clear
reasons as to why see I'd be interested
for novelties sake I'm not sitting here
going yeah I'm exactly like yeah I'm not
sitting here going that movie needed
something it was missing yeah but I'd be
curious especially because it's not from
a time where that kind of thing is is
loaded like a if you held on to an extra
hours worth of a movie from the 90s I'm
like oh okay
like I at least check out for morbid
curiosity yes I messaged Aneesa telling
her like I'm really sorry if I offended
I was just being sarcastic cuz I don't
really want to offend her and she said
she was being sarcastic - and I can't
hear her tone in the livestream so I
read it the way how I heard it yes I
mean I prefer Batman Forever Batman and
Robin and he says the best but anyway
John really what's up really quick -
Jenna Randolph a barn goose Bongo Bongo
sorry Bongo stray dogs has been
recommended and requested a few times I
have a feeling since we just started
Demon Slayer and violet ever garden over
on the patreon something tells me that
if a new show starts up it'll probably
be Vinland saga because that is the next
most requested one however bungo stray
dogs has been requested a lot of times
so maybe not in the next wave of new
shows but sometime it's possible okay
specially if more requests come in
because a few cycles of new shows now
I've seen its name pop up a few times
alright how behind are we on the super
chance okay
you know what's funny is always hearing
people say you know or you guys want to
talk about the super cats and I don't
think we only talked about what's going
on the super chats but then we weren't
in this what we're like way behind so
we're it's six oh eight cats with never
looser and in seven twenty we're like an
hour
ten minutes behind all right and we also
have stream labs oh yeah talking about
[ __ ] love these lives never lose your
nerve we don't catch up we might have to
we're gonna get at least only 60 minutes
behind wait we're gonna get there we
might need to tighten up some of their
freestyling but thank you now we don't
need a low tire what now we have to
freestyle never lose your nerd don't be
a part of the herd are you a blurred or
a nerd that's just mostly like in my way
don't look at me don't look at Greg
sometimes approval you want to rhyme
never Lula's you worry removal you want
to rhyme from the channel I'm
interrupting you and I to me
interrupting you play the tape back
that's the one thing in life I wish
there was is just like an rewind that
let's do the replay why to keep
recording we stop life if we rewind it
you're welcome Jenna Randolph wait I'm
sorry who we're doing we're doing never
lose your nerd okay all right here we go
here we go
you want a rhyme would never lose your
nerd well your rhymes make you sound
like a total turd yes
early-bird has the word would never lose
your nerd but I gotta tell you what
happened to the [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't that's
the ending part you start going I just I
guess I got served you guys of course
and Star Wars rebels that's you've been
catching up on his us oh good good me
happy every video that does not have
10,000 views go and watch that please
you know which means a ton to me is like
there are channels that I love swara
that I then I'll just go back and watch
old videos of just because I like that
channel I like those people and I want
the comfort of watching that episode and
if anybody ever does that with one of
our videos and
I found that out like that would mean
that like that would touch me in a
special way so I can touch you in a
special way
now you're gonna have to apologize to me
Julian when I'm most excited for a what
I'm loving in this chat right now is
that anis is getting a lot of love is
what I want to hear everyone loves and
the other thing too is for DC fandom I'm
excited for the new Batman game to come
out whoo catching up on that played
Arkham Asylum now I got three more games
to beat before the DC phantom event
comes around you got time you got time
Daniel Travis is back in black with an
attack Doom Patrol is very trippy I need
a white okay I feel like I'm watching
them in the right order
umbrella Academy then Doom Patrol
because I hear doom patrols like it's
really weird and out there too
but Umbrella Academy also is so I'm just
kind of wondering like if I started this
right but Doom Patrol is two seasons I'm
Braille Academy's one so logistically it
just made sense if I if I started off
with Umbrella Academy first plus you're
a huge My Chemical Romance fan
Daniel Travis also says I am starting to
watch Gotham have you guys watched that
show Tim Travis well has either of us I
don't know I don't know I got news for
you teens anybody watched I don't know
if anybody in this room has seen Gotham
I know I've seen all of god
what do you have I've seen all of it all
of Gotham like every episode watch
alongs of Gotham are on patron did you
just finish season five I finished the
whole show like just recently finished a
whole show and it's all available for $5
I did a video yesterday where I
mentioned now watch the whole thing oh I
guess you don't watch that video man a
picture what didn't happen you know what
I watch that video stream along videos
or it didn't happen that's what I say
and they should all be available for $5
on our patreon what the [ __ ] but
appreciate the super chat thank you
thank you so much Daniel Travis Ciel
Bartlett LBE
rewatch whoa hello walk away
senile Bartlett we got you got to go for
the Bartlett Elle Bartlett dreamy or the
Josh Hartnett that's the ceiling
Elle Bartlett dreamier then Josh
Hartnett my pet she got superpowers the
witch scarlet oh that's a good one take
me around flying on your magic carpet
yeah lb one two three asking a question
for I get me starlit beautiful star let
Bartlet coming for your outlets to
charge her phone rewatched Band of
Brothers mainly been catching up on
animes and anime movies your name a
silent voice love yours are great pics
movies don't know those great I've heard
of these movies and I have lately become
more and more fascinated by anime movies
because there are some incredible titles
out there there's one that's that's this
called like the time I was reincarnated
as a slime or something like that and
there's also one that's like let me eat
your liver whoo and it's like apparently
like a medical drama or some [ __ ] like
that it's like really heart-wrenching
and and dramatic and not like
action-packed so I am fascinated by the
naming of animation motion pictures
Olivia can you just come in here if
you're gonna be in the live stream
Jackie just walk in here woman get in
here
cuz I'm gonna talk mad [ __ ] mad poops
and now I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants Bradley
Bledsoe right you're brand new patron
Bradley Bledsoe we got a rhyme this shiz
oh [ __ ] we got to find the flow as we
talk about Bradley Bledsoe and don't you
know that when I let my train go I start
to sew the words together
and I go blow Bradley Bledsoe and so I
like to go down on him like Margaret Cho
went down on another comedian because I
don't know how to properly end you hey
guys I just wanted to pop in from
patreon Thank You Bradley the way I feel
more than gladly to be talking to you
Bradley main let me catch up
excellent to each other and party on
dude excellent to each other and party
on dudes yes Bradley you know as funny
as is dirty D I've watched Dirty Dancing
recently but it keeps coming up in like
conversations in interviews I amory like
people love dirty dancing apparently
half the tracks on the second idols
album are about dirty dancing I'm glad
to have your Bradley yeah thank you
[ __ ] rock man and thank you for
joining our patreon look out for that
show dude ok are we at least only an
hour behind dude at 6:25 we're almost an
hour behind right now mr. Vash who is
from 6:25 and mr. have we shouted out
mr. but you already know we are trapped
in this [ __ ] I was watching mr.
Magoo and I thought I missed it with you
and I thought of qingluan the Mortal
Kombat game wouldn't you want to do the
mountain Dew with you my first super
chat to anyone on YouTube thank you did
we get the mic catch we got two first
timers today and and that weirdly means
a lot thank you
Palm Springs is now my favorite movie of
this year you guys are awesome [ __ ] I've
been hearing a lot about this Palm
Springs thing and was easily we're gonna
have to watch Palm Springs going make me
watch gone with the wind
well you know counsel I agreed advice of
five hour long movie you could easily
watch
watch it just watch Palm Springs on your
phone for the first time and a half and
then catch the next three hours and then
you'll know what happened oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright thank you so much don't be
fooled by the that maybe we'll watch the
Morbius reader trailer don't be fooled
by the this them saying it's the best
live stream in this chat they're talking
they're talking about because about
Anissa and Olivia in the chat there's
nothing to our doing these woman's
stealing man what the [ __ ] man and one
of us being a white man I mean that's
just unacceptable or take it out the
back door I'm gonna floor you with my
rhymes you can adore me all the time by
Maria Haman I feel like we've really
annoyed the hell out of her Oh bye Maria
oh come on let's play backgammon Maria
Haman do you know a Maria out of the
room
is there evidence of this or salmon or
are you just saying that because she's
leaving now cuz she's leaving okay
alright she's a mother and she has
probably more responsibilities Maria's
little man storage on no we're doing
good we can't catch up Lance door
release in poison via spores and you
wanted to shut these rhymes up okay it's
[ __ ] Lance alright alright alright
okay Lance now right now I gotta take a
chance and maybe I can go on a dance and
prance around with my man Lance cuz he
took the stance he ain't engaged to his
girl right now and he bought her a cow
and then he's gonna take it to the
bedroom and plow ooh
how with with a real-life cow or a sow
or chairman now I'm happy for the female
representation in this chat how did it
Wow it's
women do rule III believe women and I
believe men where do I go why are you
always on about women standing because I
want to be one
Lance doors sup boy I think I feel like
some real friendships have been forming
in this livestream it's been great what
that makes that heart women supporting
each other
dude woman's my mean last lat like last
week someone was like getting a date in
their Gmail so this is a much better
development sup boys Thank You Lance
door I think they should leave Wolverine
out for a while because the hype for his
return would be awesome if they did it
right of course
lol I know man I'm with you Lance D get
like Ali Wong to play Ali Y is who we've
been needing as Wolverine all this time
Ali Wong is who I've been imagining when
I've been looking directly at those
comic book panels that are imagined for
me I'm just saying this isn't Wolverine
she needs to be pregnant I appreciate
the super chat buddy but yeah I agree
with you I'd second Batman on second
that I believe you dogs per se T is B
ACK oh man we are so close
oh we know we are on time over only 57
minutes behind yeah man we're going
better than we so we can we can take
like 20 minutes for this answer oh man
freestyle for another 20 let's do this
no more efficiency that's what I say
Percy Tremlett richard armitage for
wolverine in the MCU who played Thorin
Oakenshield
in The Hobbit films already playing
Captain America oh he was one of those
dudes in the elevator right nope I have
no [ __ ] idea Richard Armitage was in
Captain him he's at Captain America the
first adventure do you guys know who
Richard Armitage played in Captain
America the First Avenger semana John Z
one of his boys the Schmo down guy he's
not one of his like boys I did better in
one Schmo down match and so now
I'm gonna rub it in your face for at
least a week like I've never done before
no no one else even though the view
count those matches are no one here the
amount as they were on your free-for-all
so I have to I have to really put it out
nerdy by nature I'm a big fan of women
hu you yeah yeah please spread the word
spread the word by all means yeah I
played there you go you played the
assassin Heinz Kruger see some people in
the chat yeah we're Chris and Chris dude
and apparently he's an assassin
Olivia really ignore ignore you 95%
Olivia normally 99% of the time she's a
[ __ ] lie - t-mac is back
t-mac is back ready to give us a heart
attack
whoa John save the ride take your d'emic
two seasons Porlock Empire is the
greatest to ever be put on television
have you guys ever watched all the real
girls no we haven't I've seen some
Boardwalk Empire Terence winter who
worked on the Millat of The Sopranos
he's one of the main writers for it he's
actually the main I think he's
spearheading the new Batman show for HBO
max the Gotham show that is true yeah so
I said I think when I [ __ ] knew it and
that's why I was mentioning it this
whole time ya know I mean especially
with the Boardwalk Empire pedigree I
like I boardwalk Empire's one of those
shows that's on my like eventually I'm
gonna watch that list to Steve become
the skinny Steve pisghetti do you want
some more whiskey have you seen my
name's Asti spaghetti shammy have you
seen the Steve Buscemi eyes
where they just put Steve Buscemi's eyes
on all guys celebrities Thank You t-mac
lenay back at it Thank You Lynnae you
don't need a super chat anymore him I'd
appreciate that
Lynnae system hey thanks for the prayers
and yes I will message you privately and
I have also been rewatching The Big Bang
Theory
bazinga I bet I can tell you where she's
been watching it yes in Texas
HBO Beck's best streaming service on the
world I have they have options hey have
a couple options you go to dinners or
sections like crunchyroll you might find
find a solid five solid handful of anime
you might find a cool couple of shows
own I'm telling you Johnny got
acknowledged Aneesa she's gonna be mad
Aneesa uh hi oh did you just get here
I've been talking to these successful
motion picture trolls - hey oh no we
were there oh damn what is it who's this
deflated Bradley is who that is Brady
dude - faded deflated and read I'm faded
Brady deflated Brady deflated Brady
watched wait rhymes no we have to run we
don't move now we haven't lined with
deflated Brady lated Brady I once knew a
lady and I had her deflated called her
Brady and then she loved all that I was
talking about and she began to hate me
don't mean to come across all shady with
you deflated Brady but but me lately I
feel like I'm running at [ __ ] say what
spirited away for the first time loved
it that's got to be the next studio
Gulabi thing to watch man spirited away
is great I saw it for the first time
when we went back east for my
grandmother's funeral no my
grandfather's funeral but but that that
movie is beautiful and and the food
alone is holy [ __ ]
so good learning was your when was your
grandfather's funeral 20 18 years ago
yeah 20 were you watching spirited away
there at the funeral it was protected I
don't want to continue this joke but
obviously it's like just enough time
make the switch come I think my my
Gramps would have liked spirited away
personally but yeah but we've made a lot
of messed up jokes on our private time
am i that's for joking about him popping
out of the Greek oh I want that actually
as like when I'm in if I have an open
casket funeral I want my body rigged so
they can suck and scare people as they
approach have you pretty funny dude and
then on my tombstone I want them to
stuff one of my arms so you can do a
cool handshake with it you know where
you're in the end of the livestream when
it's primarily Erik and Anissa and Ryan
Beatty going back and forth people who
care about us and not the topic at hand
Erik horsemen love to the real reject
family
thank you area love goes right back to
you up your bunghole
because that's how you like to take it
rizo gaming only only a guy I will not
joke about your bunghole just yet
bye Yasmine hi bye bye Yasmine and hello
see William Blackman don't worry if you
don't know how to super chat yet just
you being here and watching for years is
loves okay and if you super chat now we
will be behind we are behind its AF and
we have stream labs as well gaming love
you Eric Anissa me me Greg
John and Olivia dude dude Olivia's
gained so much love olivia gets all the
love i mean that's why we do these sure
she's getting more love from you guys
and she ever gets from me and Eric
horseman says right back same rizzo with
two hearts you know that love is I love
when you guys chat with each other
in the supership that is a yeah that's
the way everyone should be conversing
with each other even when we're not
live-streaming just through the super
chat just people do you do with your
stream laughs okay send all of your text
through stream labs uh Anissa says I
feel as though y'all are both my
therapist's which is why she tips so
much I mean you don't want us to be your
therapist you don't I mean what it would
be like Hannibal the cannibal in terms
I'd be Hannibal Lecter therapist style
if you wanted me to be your therapist
and I'll be the emotional vampire from
what we do in the shadows the TV yeah
sure man I mean I appreciate that in me
so that's really sweetie but you trust
me you don't want us to be your son your
therapist replacement you don't although
she does go on to say that the reject
family means the world
oh thank you guys so much for going back
and forth in here what are you doing
John I am changing the crops so that we
can see all the rest of the super test
because we hit the bottom we've hit the
bottom we've hit the bottom we've hit
the bottom of the super chance we've
smacked that ass man the bottom line
would want to wrap up the stream labs
boogie bug all right so who's after
Aneesa
we got a reject family means the world
to me Erik horsemen followed that up
only thing getting me through this time
Aneesa is the reject family and what
that's camp Beach that can't be true
Erik no stop lying Eric you mentioned a
bunch of films and shows so you were
watching Erik horsemen that are really
helping you get through tough times
right now yeah okay and then it needs to
goes onto stoner oh yeah needs to goes
on to say Greg you mean the world to me
truly when I first joined I connected
with you first
Jon just snuck in there and stole my
heart I love y'all both goddamn right I
connected with you first Greg usually
does it's true and correct always talks
about himself in first person it's a way
to do it it's the way to do it that's
how people know that you're important
Greg feels uncomfortable about revealing
that fact about himself don't worry
Greg is losing his mind Greg's all right
cuz Bret Peterson's back Bret Petersen
we've refused to thank you so much man
the guy looks very
first time we've been here and like
you've been contributing so much in this
job thank you so much my dude okay thank
you
where the [ __ ] are you doing thanks guys
you've helped stop interrupting while
trying to read this is coming here is
friendly comedy moment the moment where
it happens so good thanks guys you
helped me with my anxiety for as long as
I can remember that's awesome I mean not
that you have anxiety but really happy
to have helped but watch Outer Banks and
re-watched stranger things
I don't know Outer Banks dude I can't
believe we'd help you with your anxiety
I mean that means a lot man seriously as
anxious to really know how we've been
able to help with your anxiety but yes
to anxious individuals it's pretty cool
we can help out with your much loves
here I'm happy and I'd love to know what
we're doing so that I can apply that
just to myself constantly make us a
playlist of the videos of ours that Sue
the you will check those out but that
means a hell of a lot dude thank you
that really does you know it all means a
lot but especially hearing if we can
take your mind off something like that
like that means mean I'm like Elmo what
the [ __ ] does that mean what a weird
Elmo we should talk an Elmo right here
no I'm like Elmo cuz you're cuddly and
you're good-natured man then why aren't
I the Cookie Monster that's a great
question here's to healthy man yeah
people like the Cookie Monster when he's
binging cookies not only he's talking
about how they're sometimes food so see
what you see Thank You Brett Peterson's
really sweet really yeah see William
King see William Blackman is the last
one right now first time super chat wait
a minute literally the first time do we
need to rhyme with see William Black
Milk see William Blackman see William
Blackman be taken to action with this
super chattin yeah and he whips out the
claws call him hugh jackman throwing the
dice like backgammon
i guess he really likes our reactions
mr. William Blackmun joining a faction
with the quirky mercs when you clear
something up in this live stream we
already talked plenty about this
Halloween kills doesn't show us much
enough to merit like a 10 minute video
and we're both gonna see it when it
comes out I was confused thinking that
it was already footage reads that way I
thought it was just the end I thought it
was a trailer teaser for what's to come
and now the fire department is gonna
[ __ ] it all we haven't seen the Morbius
we're trailer yet we would love to
though I love aldo jones
do you know if you can't super Chad
never apologize never apologize for that
never apologize for such a thing
especially you a nice I swear to [ __ ]
god
can't super Chad just drop a like on the
video it helps now if Eric horseman is
saying this though if Erica needs to
can't super checked no no whoa whoa I
just said Aneesa it's okay I was free
she's free I am gonna risk not if I
don't want to risk of any way to rash
just now I'm sorry
horsemen by Elijah I'll commit seppuku
later by Elijah I never want this stream
to get more than a hundred viewers the
rate we go out with these comments I
really like let me expand this window
one more zero oh no like Elmo who speaks
in the third person
oh I get it Katie things there we go to
the last I'm not cuddly we got you are
so cuddly
oh we're no what do you say first time
at the super chat want support you guys
just watch prisoners the other day so
dark it's so great prisoners is a movie
that needs to be seen by way way more
people I need to show a Livi adapt I got
a skip the first few minutes the shoot a
deer yeah yeah yeah then they spit on
the deer and they call the deer up [ __ ]
Freeman then you play as the deer for
the last half of the kick yeah
that's a great movie though like and I'm
all wait like that has one of its weird
I don't know why but that movie Jake
Gyllenhaal's performance is one of my
all-time favorite motion picture
performances like he's so great I said I
didn't want to go below a hunt I didn't
want to go above 100 but no but now
we're not below I want to be exactly 100
okay let's get the 200 you a [ __ ]
that's good too much all right I'm
trying my damnedest to show this last
chat and for some reason I can't get the
window low enough so Eric Horstman could
do this all night
ha ha ha much love to Anissa Rizzo
gaming me VM Olivia and of course my
guys John angry of course
Eric horseman no I love the [ __ ] out of
you thank you Eric but please it's ok
you don't have to contribute anymore for
tonight yeah just just for tonight go
back to the go back to working this this
week go go do the thing where you're
selling your body and let it need to
know I let her know I mean I was
passionate and Issa Eric's gonna let you
know I didn't mean to yell at you
alright we were solved and you heard
aneesa's feelings look who's in the chat
mom and dad were solving a little issues
his feelings look at the chat I know I
take full responsibility I'm a hurtful
guy I hate everyone I'm the Frog person
and dude but Rizzo gaming thinks man
such a sweet thing to say
Katy Orlando are you in actual Florida
or is that just your name craw meant
below help me out here alright we're
gonna get this ready er than you've ever
been in your life to use the Australian
pronunciation so who did we do last we
did hitman Hudson but we did an earlier
hitman husband which was this one so
miles I'll second Kyle Sackett bring out
the racket I'm gonna hack it with Kyle
Sackett boom getting in the bracket will
be a tan line maggots I don't
that let me just retract it watch the
end credits currently roll-up thanks
okay okay hold up Greg
watching the end credits currently
rolling on the last of us to somehow was
successful in avoiding spoilers now I
have hours of reviews to watch
starting with hours with you with yours
of course thanks for all you do gents
dude our hours of gaming your review is
gonna be the first Kyle I appreciate
that man I mean you don't mention here
if you actually enjoyed the game or not
[ __ ] that game I did I did III do want a
shout-out I did do a livestream with a
nice Anissa and Eric horseman LAN bade
achhe asan ECOMOG from struggle nation
and a girl named my who I just met that
day but yeah we did like an hour and 45
minutes spoiler talk on the Last of Us
and we all had varying opinions drew
being the one who really didn't like it
and it was actually I thought a really
great discussion you know it was it's
like I wish the internet could usually
be he wouldn't disagreeing because we
all managed to really be respectful in
spite of all of us having very different
opinions which I thought was great so
you're all a [ __ ] about it yeah maybe
I'll end up on SJW [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] all
we all conformed to cancel culture
that's right
cancel it but Thank You Kyle socket and
chill level TV move from our super chats
on YouTube over to here to stream laughs
thank you
I've watched the Mission Impossible
series No Country for Old Men
Hamilton willow and then black Atlanta
wide variety the skeleton twins space
force defy Bloods onward parasite I'm
watching food wars my hero academia
Family Guy South Park and friends it's a
lot and the one thing he's not watching
is this life oh boy
damn dude that's crazy that's a lot
you're the why out of anyone I know
you're the one who's caught up on the
most right now yeah
you have caught are you such a fault you
know why don't you sitting the cheese I
kneel spy I didn't wanna do my own be
your own self she's not correct time to
be sat backwards
I'll get Olivia at the very end to say
bye hmm chief I'm not gonna wanna show
up on scurry don't ring the shame bell
cheating on me
right now Yeah right now yeah so you
know is that when I'm doing the
livestream that's right time she's in an
entanglement Greg she's in an
entanglement hit man Hudson back at it
again network is the thank you hit man
how it's especially for big thanks to
the ones who also came over here on the
stream the stream glasses that's I know
it's gonna be inconvenient but it is
better network is the best film ever
made
it makes the Godfather look like daddy's
home - OH shots fired
daddy's home - what a specific pool I
mean daddy's home - is pretty great so
if you're saying that it elevates the
Godfather's home - is a lot like I don't
know what you're talking about that
one's it's pretty great oh here we go
Catherine Ana Katie and with the plan
I'm a man
euro woman I look at the through the
looking-glass and I gotta check my own
ass because I often find that I'm a big
fan of this girl named Katie and
occasionally I become the fan like how
Eminem has his own stand and then I feel
like sometimes I run but I already ran
to her page but she'd let me out of the
cage and now we're here on the stage as
I'm looking up at Katie saying you're a
wonderful lady and lately I just want to
talk to you in a British accent like
Ryan paid a loving Gotham extremely
grateful for the inspiration deathly
addicted at crime documentaries I
can't help myself and yes the scary
video reactions I usually end up
sleeping with the lights on oh there is
the hunt good all right oh and hey KTM
I'm really glad because I'm glad those
episodes are working for you again
because we had some issues getting
access to the Gotham episodes but now
they're available to everyone who
subscribes that tier so yeah man Thank
You Katie yeah I mean yeah I would talk
about you should really check out Katie
Ann's through the looking-glass blog
site she's really great at what she does
yes I mean that in the most sincere way
[ __ ] great at what she does
yeah man watch Gotham [ __ ] underrated
show yes get entangled with Gotham ooh
ooh Oh Olivier there is something I've
been watching [ __ ] unsolved mysteries
yeah not BuzzFeed which is unsolved
mysteries is a classic like unsolved
mysteries has been around for years and
they just revitalize yeah yeah I've been
watching unsolved mysteries damn how is
always satisfied how is it cuz like I
I've watched the old Robert Stack ones
like a lot as a kid and now like I
haven't gotten to see the new one yet is
it
it's pretty good no you know me me I'm
not happy that you are not in support of
the real rejects rap album
don't think I don't see you just because
you actually know music doesn't mean we
shouldn't give it a shot let us get
entangled with some rap alright
what the [ __ ] Eric horsemen as long as
you keep super chatting it's not gonna
be a freestyle album yeah it'll be
written I mean my part will be freestyle
my part will be written and his part
will be freestyle and oh thank you right
I'll make the beats will be run the
jewels I'll make the beats and we'll
both ride all right Eric know where it
me Mia oh [ __ ] or let me me em where it
me me alright well this is a different
Mimi but either way it's a Mimi alright
it's a different Mimi no I think is Mimi
unless somebody disputes that
well I'm seeing around here yeah yeah
okay differ different me me or the same
me me is this me me am laramie me you're
being mean in the chat so here's what
her super chat says hey guys really want
that real features ought to include to
change Juicy J actually a 2 Chainz
feature would probably be good I can't
count on Juicy J we were talk Oh trust
me you don't want us to be singing I we
were talking about this on discord so I
wanted to ask Greg it is the same Mimi
alright have you seen fleabag if not
highly recommend you start that rap
album I think you would like the humor
as much as I love your rap am I wrong
and also your rap sounds like Eminem
impression and it's going down this
regression I'm changing uploads I don't
mean no that I only know that that
Eminem flow or I go into Chili Peppers
and that doesn't even
I even forget the way that flow goes I
[Music]
haven't seen playback no I haven't no
we're not gonna get [ __ ] looking I
don't think I think I saw the first
episode of flea bag I didn't continue
for some reason I should I hear flea bag
is amazing feeds a wallet bridge yeah
yeah yeah and Andrew Scott ISM she plays
a key - oh so did she really phase out
the tree Oh
droid droid I've seen an episode or two
a fleabag I don't know if I'm not sure I
could pin it to your taste exactly but I
bet you would like it dude inhuman quake
is saying we inspired him to start a
YouTube channel oh I hope it was this
stream cuz you could look upon you
future in glee and and just as you said
that Mimi wrote a comment saying that
she's gonna courage the rap from now on
so start where's Anissa where is an
Anissa
you better not be working at the
hospital right now okay cuz that's not
accept Nisa I don't know where is Anissa
okay - but thank you now I have I'll
watch it sometime Eric Eric Eric just
finished the last Kingdom great show
especially if you are a Vikings fan
which I know a lot of Vikings fans
actually look upon Eric and I feel like
he's from one of the daleks miss the
last Kingdom yeah yeah man I [ __ ]
Viking shit's so hot right now man that
Hansel's so hot right now it's really
none of the Vikings I'm trying to I'm
trying to get Anissa to get it whoa bill
waters I didn't intend to hurt her
feelings but if I did I will commit
seppuku on this live stream oh do get us
demonetised with you were I'm blaming
you for what I did well yeah yeah that's
fair I appreciate this the super chair
I'm assuming this is horseman
yes horseman I'm gonna well that's a
good question
yeah might be a different earth judging
by the amount I would guess it was Eric
horses I couldn't tell you oh [ __ ]
well either way oh oh thank you well
thank you Eric and then dr. balls
mahogany dr. balls mahogany I want you
in front of me with the economy of your
mahogany but then you're committing this
act of misogyny and I I feel like your
life could be a bit of a comedy but
right now you're landing me in the realm
of dramedy mr. balls mahogany dr. balls
mahogany sounds like the guy at the end
of like a manscaped commercial like
here's our founder balls mahogany balls
mahogany was tired of not having a good
enough well gave his buff so the next
the next live stream
my ass isn't we're gonna come in here
we're gonna be like look look we decided
in the middle of the first super chat to
rhyme everyone's names
yeah we're gonna come with a whole new
attitude next week we're gonna come in
like great [ __ ] tear [ __ ] like a punk
rock [ __ ] yeah we're gonna call that
freestyle live speech super check your
words and we go rhyme all this [ __ ] we
didn't have Beats we're gonna have a DJ
is gonna get off the chain
Disney oh yeah god is he buys the rights
to the Bible was a great video well done
thank you doctor hell yeah took me about
two and a half hours to write a few
hours to shoot it a couple hours for
graphics couple hours of editing and I
like the way it's turned out I did I did
I felt like a charred they didn't like
it did she answer for her action I never
want to see a Chara at another one of
these family get-togethers from here on
out that's a good thing Corona is
happening because I'm gonna make sure a
Chara gets laughing at my video enough
laughing to my specifications exactly
that yes I do have an apology video to
record also the better know I'm trying
at home I think she usually watches from
our phones and maybe her phone died when
she's had work the past couple of
weekends but but I told you sure from
7:00 a.m. to 7 p.m.
oh all 24 of those hours and then Kyle
sack get back at it
Hey yeah we're I'm you just can't think
about it you just let it come sometimes
it just really comes to you watch what
happens when I don't think I start
seeing my shrink and then you know
before I'm thinking of the color pink
and then I like to fight Zelda with Linc
and what happens when I do a little bit
of a left wink
stay healthy take some zinc John Doe I
recovered it Kyle sack and I really
appreciate it
many aspects of the game assuming this
was the last of us part three of course
art design was gorgeous voice acting and
characters were superb I can see how the
story divided many but I enjoyed it
overall not sure how to feel about time
percentage given to the character he's
talking about the fact that he plays
Joel for way too long and yeah it's not
enough I agree I'm not really hurry up
and get to Abbey
yeah can we kill this join the chat anis
is back [ __ ] yeah
and yeah yeah I respect your opinion man
but I'm curious to know what you thought
I mean in terms of like okay I mean you
just finish this you're digesting it so
I'm here to see if it grows on you or if
it lessens in European yeah thanks
shrinks thanks for sharing let's say I
have a civil [ __ ] conversation about
the goddamn game Matic about how the
possibilities of how this could have
gone wrong beech also the discord is
just like a forum through our patreon
mostly we technically have to but really
the one with actual people and it is the
patreon one so if you want to come in
and chat there a multiple comment board
I want pizza it's pizza night there are
multiple comment boards many are
dedicated to shows we watch on patreon
some are also dedicated to other [ __ ] so
if you need to know what the discord is
that's why don't you bring us into the
shower with you Anissa dude we could
have guested you in the slide stream is
the place for shower and then chill
level TV I think our last one of the
night could be could be we haven't
checked the other one yet no it looks
like the last one of the night cuz in
the actual stream labs app it appears to
be so awesome
Hulu versus Netflix versus Disney plus
versus prime thank you by the way for
his prime video which one is the best
are you guys gonna do more skater video
reactions and skits yeah I just put out
a skit this week
now and we'll put out a scary video
reaction likely to just put out a skit
scary videos are like a weekly issue so
at least you got that and then a sketch
another skit will come out in like you
know three or four or five months yeah
we'll see it kind of hard there are no
big movies it has to be put together
somehow we fall like eight days behind
on everything else are we gotta you
touch your letters only been like four
loads this week ketchup
anyway adora you'll get your apology
video today okay who lubbers nefesh well
I think Netflix is still the best it's
really hard at Top Netflix now it's like
of course are there programs or certain
things on these other streaming services
that I'm not gonna get on Netflix
because they were exclusively on those
other ones yeah so of course I got a hop
to those but for me Netflix is still the
most consistent one it's goes beyond
more than just being the most
influential one are you ever surprised
you didn't less I mean yeah you did
prime video I think with prime video
that thing is great is that they also
have the rental option if you want to
like you know like I'm a I don't have it
for free here but you can at least rent
this and that's cool it all comes in one
package I would say HBO max is probably
the weakest one of them that are on here
right now unless you are about HBO
original program yeah of course then
it's just [ __ ] HBO at that point but
I think Netflix is still the best one
like they they seem to stand the test of
time and they they're still dish like
they're theirs they've shot so much [ __ ]
in advance that they're releasing stuff
that like oh [ __ ] I don't even realize
Netflix have this in the India and the
can ready to put out here you know what
I mean oh yeah I would say Netflix or a
prime video and the only reason I would
throw prime towards the top there is
because of the selection angle of well
yeah even if it's not streaming for free
you can technically access it from there
so the convenience level is high exactly
but yeah Netflix is probably King
because HBO and and the others okay then
we got one more from Aneesa here Jon
this is the best way to keep so
this last Super chat from Mesa and speed
ratted questions in the live streams and
then Greg Jose gets a taco from Del Taco
not real taco adèle aid
don't don't don't sell del Taco short
alright I will sit down del Taco
not Dan and but dan the del taco guy Dan
anis is saying I still want my apology
video from John John
lol John give her your apology video now
listen guys it's recently come to my
attention that some of my actions have
not been you know what you guys want
from me and they're not good and I hear
you I've been going back through all of
my old tweets racing everything I've
said about Aneesa
because they are unacceptable but also I
don't really take responsibility because
you know life is hard and I was drunk at
the time I was a different person
different person then you can't blame
your damn astonished at my action my
upbringing and my upbringing and God
doesn't want me to be happy and but I
take ownership and take ownership but I
don't know how this happened
sorry can I still act was this enough
that I can still have my career
wait are you drunk John no not really
I'm more to drink than me well I
demonstrated of the beer yes this beer
that I've almost found mean you know
like I think I get a little drunker than
you because you know if the beer I have
there usually a higher percentage or so
you know just like naturally but I'm not
drunken and then Eric horseman has
actually topped it off with saying
cheers to the best channel ever and best
fan thank you that's a [ __ ] out of you
man love you buddy
seriously I hope you're doing alright
yes see I had a leap I did a mix with
one drink here but now we're not drunk I
can sober up right now watch me be sober
that's my favorite is over whenever I
want my favoritism people get drunk and
really prove they're not drunk which is
amazing look flamey-o a street line so I
can walk on it in a straight line
yeah Beach cancel John cancel meth
alright god I don't do man so let's see
come on speed round this up no we're
thank you for everyone who contributed
and stream lads and the super chats
means the [ __ ] done thank you seriously
it means a [ __ ] done but let's we're
gonna we're gonna close the loophole
there and then yeah speed round here of
any questions every motto is have you
watched the order no next question black
chocolate what else do we got
ooh Death Note and dark good combo cool
hashtag cancelled John I agree with that
Hansel mess let's hold off let's not get
ahead of ourselves
listen meth has done a lot for this town
okay surgeon Joey also watched the neon
demon he's on a Nicolas winter
Reformation right now did you watch only
the good die young or whatever that TV
show he had was you gotta take a date
with Aneesa do it as soon as poss the
only way to gain forgiveness that's the
way you do it John watch the boys
even so beer one thing on Netflix you'd
recommend the Middleditch in Schwartz
special the most hilarious thing I've
seen all year undoubtedly haven't
laughed heart as hard at that as
anything else this year Russian doll
it's a fantastic series not as funny not
as funny Amy a little bit moment pretty
funny very inventive also very German
easy for sheezy should you watch the
hunt I'd say give it a shot and tell us
how you feel and maybe we'll watch it
then I say it's probably gonna be
alright and you'll probably be happy you
watched it on to master The Godfather
Goodfellas are the Godfather John I'm
trying to answer which one where's that
point Tyler sleep that's below this one
okay okay are you guys excited for
uncharted jurassic world starting
filming again
kind of not really not really why are
they starting fill me fill me is this a
good idea I don't want us to go either
but it's also 8:11 p.m. here The
Godfather versus good fellows depending
on the day usually more days I would
take Goodfellas though did we miss her
super chat no we didn't I shattered it
out he said cheers to the best channel
best fam ever thank you so much Eric
seriously yeah those words mean a lot
also yes I mean I didn't miss it
yes cancel haircuts and I will get a
sleeve tattoo someday more excited for
multi person madness or spider-man 3
multiverse imagine are you excited for
the rack or a Camus V this is a speed
round yeah I'm very sad for the rack
correct good movie [ __ ] eating I Roth
helped produced it what's the favorite
poster on the wall behind me ooh this
one this wood carving of the real
rejects one that was made for us love
the [ __ ] at one wonderful yeah ELISA be
crazy here that to me forever
I mean I'll [ __ ] I go to this whole wall
if I wanted to you painted one of those
yourself I would probably say the Ryan
Gosling drive one my sister my sloppy
will don't know as my sister made all
these are the wood burning my sister oh
she is she like that's Robin Williams
ash from Evil Dead John wick Ryan
Gosling terminator American Psycho and I
would say the Ryan Gosling one from
Drive is my personal faith alright John
will you ever cut your hair again to be
honest I love it long but just wondering
I think he should I feel like long as
you should shave it all off and then we
could see his real personality long as
indeed yes that is true long is where I
feel at home if I cut it again I'll
probably bring it back up to like
shoulder length or something like that I
don't see myself getting like a short
haircut anytime soon Oh Britt Peterson
thanks for the super chat dude VP keep
saying nice nice good night guys see you
on the next string Bret I want to be
from the bottom of my heart for keeping
up to par here with our folks like
Anissa Ryan and Eric or ceman you did
great today
thank you so much soon I hope to I hope
to get to know you even more now thank
you and John what's your favorite toe
what's my favorite toe probably one of
my big or little toes let's be honest I
could probably get the most range with
my little toes so I'll go with that one
banshee I haven't seen Banshee out
lisa-marie the show you you're welcome
top or bottom
I definitely be a top or bottom
depending on how much fiber I had that
day all right already time I like gay
sex or straight sex both straight sex I
forget it's been so long years a lot of
people were in that boat right now
all right dating is not easy in the
corona time stop talking about yourself
John sure think I'm just kidding
John brings [ __ ] over to his home all
the time have we seen this scary movies
or comedies scary movies movies have you
guys watched Heather's 89 yes definitely
good movie okay five more questions and
then we're saying bye John top or bottom
I don't know it depends on the day we
talked about handle earlier meaner I'm
on the last episode John wicker drive
drive John wick just play devil's
advocate all are you I'm 5 for 10 I'm 5
11 and 3/4 whatever a fanny pack I wish
they were still in style because they
would be very very convenient I have one
in the car well reactor mania ever
happen no there's too many people now
and I think some of them don't get along
anyway thank you guys so much for being
here this is because we did that's the
last question we did what did Halloween
kills teaser and it was the best thing
all year and there was too much to talk
about so we just couldn't make a video
and the shadow I would say is better
than dark man that's my personal pick I
need to see dark man actually I'm just
just throwing that out there I love
everyone who's been here thank you guys
so much for all the love
yes Rizzo reject meet up at the gas
station if you know you know and also
anis is 50 feet quarantine quarantine
hey where are your [ __ ] mask people
god damn it it's not a big deal
wear masks say inside it's mostly to
protect other people rather than
protecting yourself even if you don't
believe it does that much it's not that
hard and maybe if we all jump on board
we could get outside in an orderly
timely fashion rush it's gonna be closed
down again Trumper bite and oh oh by
didn't buy I mean Biden but also a broom
I take a broom a bucket DVD of that Hugh
Jackman political movie thank you guys
we're done weird